Guten Morgen Linus. Das ist heute unsere größte Livesendung ever. 70.000 zahlende Gäste.
Sehr gut, so ein fettes Rahmenprogramm, vier Tage muss es auch erstmal jemand nachmachen.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer 4vierund3 vom, was haben wir denn heute überhaupt eigentlich?
Zweiter Juli zwanzig zweiundzwanzig live von der Fusion im Content und wir begrüßen ganz viele Gäste. Hallo, herzlich willkommen bei Loko und Netzpolitik.
Ja, aber ganz schön anstrengend, ne, das hier alles aufzubauen.
Ja klar, also ich meine den ganzen Acker hier mähen.
Tage hat das gedauert.
Die ganzen Dixies, regelmäßig lernen, die ganze Arbeit, die wir so äh in so was reinfließen lassen.
Ja, die Leute machen sich gar keine Vorstellung davon, was es bedeutet, einen Podcast zu machen, diese Zeiten. Ja, hallo, äh wir sind's, Tim und Linus. Ich bin Tim, das ist Linus und ähm,
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir aber trotzdem mal äh zu Beginn kurz,
mal erzählen, wie wir eigentlich so äh sind? Also wir sind zusammen Logbuch Netzpolitik, ein Podcast, der wie schon vorhin anklang,
Echt seit elf Jahren sind wir jetzt schon unterwegs.
Über zehn, noch nicht ganz elf, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube Zehn-jähriges hatten wir schon irgendwann. Also wir sind auf jeden Fall schon so lange auf Sendung, dass wir nicht mehr wissen, wie lange wir auf Sendung sind und machen das in der Regel so wöchentlich, so Pi mal Daumen, klappt manchmal besser. Stets bemüht.
Stets bemüht, genau.
Und wir sind so äh so Internet-Hallodris würde ich mal sagen, also ich zumindest. Irgendwie was mit Computern gemacht und dann äh auf keiner anderen Themen mehr gekommen und.
Ich bin dann bei dem Podcast gelandet und du?
Reingezerrt irgendwann in in die in die in die Konserve.
Äh ja Tim hat mich irgendwann offener CC Veranstaltung angesprochen, ob wir nicht einen Podcast gemeinsam machen wollen. Damals habe ich noch bei Netzbibliothek org geschrieben und äh da ich da grade,
gegangen war um mich in der IT-Sicherheit zu verdingen war das sehr schön das Thema weiterführen zu können und so setzen wir uns seit über zehn Jahren mit dem Internet und der Gesellschaft und äh dann eben,
der Netzpolitik auseinander, ein glaube ich sehr sehr unschöner Begriff, der auch leider zu dem wahrscheinlich nicht optimalen Titel, wir müssten ja eigentlich so was wie so ein True Crime Podcast ne, irgendwie so,
Wir bräuchten so einen geileren so einen spannenderen Titel.
Berichten wir auch die ganze Zeit über True Crimes.
Ja, es ist es sind wirklich spannende Geschichten. Lach und Sachgeschichten aus dem Netz.
Mit mit mit äh garantiert schrecklichem Ende und zwischendurch äh verschiedenen Wendungen und Aufregern. So würde ich, so würde ich das bezeichnen.
Ja, also wir haben uns auch so ein bisschen als als psychischer psychologischer Berater psychologische Beratung. Wie nennt man denn das? Begleit. Wir haben eine Hilfe für die tägliche.
Genau, wir wir wollten das also die die Podcast-Beschreibung äh ist noch von von damals, wo wo wir gesagt haben, ähm unaufgeregt das Geschehen kommentieren?
Dieses Versprechen konnten wir nicht einhalten und in der manchmal versuchen wir auch ein bisschen unterhaltsam zu sein. Ja. Geigenhuman sind sie's das.
Unterhaltsam, genau, versuchen wir dann besonders immer, wenn wir mal äh auf der Bühne sind. Ihr könnt euch vorstellen, das war in letzter Zeit jetzt mal nicht so oft. Von daher äh müssen wir uns jetzt auch erst mal äh wieder aus dem Corona befreien, was das,
aber wir haben's bisher immer so gehalten, dass wir uns mit,
Gästen äh bestücken und zwar nicht irgendwelchen Gästen, sondern wir ziehen aus unserem erweiterten Umfeld Leute heran, die im weiteren Sinne als Aktivisten äh gelten könnten.
Unabhängig davon, ob sie sich selbst so verstehen oder nicht, ob das heute der Fall ist, werden wir noch rausfinden. Ja und heute haben wir äh eingeladen.
Katharina, hallo. Äh ich glaube, ich muss mal dein Mikrofon noch mal richten.
Oh danke schön hallo.
Hallo Karl,
genau, kleiner Begrüßungsapplaus. Und wir
mit euch wollen wir uns heute ein bisschen über äh euren Aktivismus äh unterhalten oder auch unser aller äh Aktivismus in gewisser Hinsicht,
Ähm so nennt man dich ja, Katta äh ist vor allem als Autorin unterwegs mittlerweile, hat aber auch eine wilde Vorgeschichte, die werden wir uns gleich anhören,
und äh Karl ist.
Hacker oder auch Internet-Einhorn Internet schillerndes Interneteinhorn, genau. Das müssen wir auf jeden Fall äh auch gleich noch hinterfragen.
Wir haben auch ein Einhorn, da vorne sitzen sehe ich.
Also es ist sozusagen das Internationale Festival der Interneteinhörner in Schillland. Ja.
Oder? War schon mal bei uns zu Gast.
Fangen wir mit Gratte an. Das stimmt.
Ist aber ewig her.
2015 mit eine Sendung mit dem schönen Titel Radikalisierung durch Internet.
Da konntet ihr auch kaum jemanden anderen einladen, würde ich sagen. Außer euch selbst.
Das Internet hat dich radikalisiert. Oh ja.
Genau, du hast nämlich eine äh längere äh Vorgeschichte aber auch und die haben wir damals glaube ich gar nicht so sehr ähm thematisiert. Also abgesehen jetzt von der Radikalisierung durchs Internet. Aber ähm.
Muss man ja mal alle Leute, die was mit Netzpolitik fragen, ob sie was so ihre erste Computerbegegnung war.
Äh bei dir wurde es schon in die Wiege gelegt, wenn ich das äh richtig entsinne.
Ja, also wahrscheinlich meine erste Computerbegegnung ähm.
Verdrängt vermute ich mal. Also ich bin in einem IT-ler-Haushalt aufgewachsen.
Eigentlich immer Rechner gab, also wenn irgendwas Schrott war, dann hieß es Mami, mein Bildschirm ist Schrott und dann sagt sie, geh in den Keller, hol dir einen Neuen. Das heißt, ähm ja, beide Eltern programmiert.
Ist das eigentlich schlimm? Weil meine Kinder wachsen ja auch in so einem Haushalt aus äh auf und ich frage mich immer, wie das wohl so ist.
Es war supergeil. Das war ja noch eine Zeit, wo Internet richtig teuer war und wir hatten halt über die Eltern dann ähm gratis Internet, wo das halt noch recht teuer war.
Das war schon cool, ne? Also ich war hatte auch sehr früh einen Wikipedia Account, wo ich selber auch Sachen geschrieben habe und äh ja hat,
immer Internet, immer Rechner. Ich fand das vollkommen unbegreiflich, wie es anders sein kann. Ja, das hat mich dann auf Abwege gebracht.
Und deshalb aufgeregt über die Wikipedia oder wie hast du das Display kaputt gemacht.
Nee, das war, also ich habe irgendwann, also das war dann später zur Studienzeit. Ich habe erkannt, dass äh Backups äh so eine Sache sind. Manchmal funktionieren sie, manchmal funktionieren sie nicht.
Wenn man sie.
Genau und deshalb dachte ich, ist doch geil, wenn ich für Klausuren lernen muss, dann kann ich direkt den Artikel korrigieren, um das, was zu ergänzen wäre und dann ist das immer da.
Hat funktioniert.
Nee, nee, ist noch da.
Ja.
Und dann fing es aber an, dass dich dass dir die Probleme der Politik und des des Internets irgendwie in ein Dorn im Auge wurden.
Ja, es war tatsächlich zu Studienzeiten. Ähm ich habe damals Politik und Wirtschaft in Münster studiert und damals fing diese Diskussion um die Vorratsdatenspeicherung an, also Vorratsdatenspeicherung bedeutet,
der Staat die Internet und die Kommunikationsanbieter verpflichten wollte auf Vorrat von allen zu speichern wer wann mit wem telefoniert hat,
Standortdaten ähm noch beim Smartphone, also Handy damals ähm mit dabei und damals wurde auch noch drüber diskutiert, den E-Mail-Betreff.
Zu speichern und ich fand das unerhört. Ja, also ich mir war also ich habe ausm Fenster geguckt, dachte, wo ist die riesen Demo? Habe sie nicht gesehen,
Ähm ja, dann habe ich dann so einen Vicky gefunden vom Arbeitskreis gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die sich damals so bundesweit in ganz vielen Städten gegründet haben und äh ja, haben wir,
gemeinsam organisiert und dann ging's immer weiter, würde ich sagen.
Der AK Vorrat, wenn man ihn so schön nannte, der eigentlich auch.
Fast gar nicht. Oder? Also geben tut's ihm einerseits glaube ich noch,
Sie noch? Vielleicht verpasse ich jetzt gerade irgendwas oder erinnere mich nicht richtig, aber so in der Art und in der Form und dieser breiten Aufstellung.
Für ein einzelnes Thema? Gab's das so vorher? Gar nicht, oder?
Ich glaube, das kannst du vielleicht besser bewerten als ich aufgrund des.
Siehst du mal, wie gut das funktioniert. Ja. Nicht mehr aufgrund des Alters.
So lange her.
Oder so oder so. Äh nee, das war schon ganz geil, weil da sehr viele unterschiedliche Leute da hinzugekommen sind, ne. Also da waren einerseits Leute, die ähm was mit IT gemacht haben oder zumindest einen IT-Background hatten.
Aber halt auch Leute die aus ja anderen aktivistischen Umfeldern kamen und einfach gesagt haben so ja das Thema hat mich jetzt getriggert ne also da geht's ja nicht nur,
darum ähm also irgendwie das also ist halt auch schlimm, dass man in Gespräche mit meiner Oma dann halt äh auf Vorrat äh festgehalten werden von allen ähm,
sondern halt auch Beratungsstellen, ne. Also wenn ich beispielsweise bei einer Selbsthilfegruppe anrufe, Seelensorge, ne und beim Psychologen,
Aufgrund dieser Datenspur kannst du ja superviel über eine Person rausfinden und äh mir war's vollkommen unbegreiflich,
das in einer Demokratie wollen kann. Jetzt muss man sagen, ich bin gebürtig aus Polen, das heißt ich bin mit so Horrorgeschichten über übergriffige Staaten, auch groß geworden und mit Akten, die dann,
später dann ähm ja Verwandte dann halt irgendwo rausgepult haben,
ja mir war's vollkommen unverständlich, wie man halt irgendwie so eine digitale Spur von jemandem erfassen will, ne, der halt nix gemacht hat. Warum?
Hat dir bestimmt dein Computerverständnis schon mal auch äh erheblich geholfen, weil ich entsinne mich noch gut? Also mittlerweile ist das nicht mehr so, aber,
lange Zeit,
Wurde das ja als nicht so schlimm gesehen, weil es ja nur es ist ja nicht das Gespräch, was aufgenommen wird und der Klassiker des Abhörens, ja, des Überwachens, war ja immer so dieses ich nehme auf, was du sagst.
Natürlich sowieso nicht, klar aber diese ganzen Verbindungsdaten und so, das ist alles so technischer Kram. Heute sind wir mehr in dieser wer hat uns verraten, Mütterdaten äh.
Diesen Moment angekommen. Also ich nehme das so wahr, dass dass das mittlerweile ein ganz anderes äh Verständnis dafür gibt, weil,
einfach auch kollektiv alle mehr Erfahrung damit gesammelt haben.
Ja klar, aber damals war's ja auch so, da hatte noch nicht jeder ein Smartphone, ne,
Handy hatten schon viele und aber es ist klar anhand der Datenspur kannst du halt sagen wenn ich jemand nachts um drei anrufe dann ist das wahrscheinlich eine Person mit der ich eng bin ne und,
Halt bei äh der Seelensorge anrufe, dann geht's mir halt gerade vielleicht nicht so gut, ne? Oder halt irgendwie beim juristischen Hilfsdienst, was auch immer und äh von daher war für mich überhaupt, also es war halt so ein Quatschargument, ne, also wären ja keine Inhalte.
Ja
Gar nicht, ne? Also manchmal reicht's zu wissen, dass du jemanden um eine gewisse Uhrzeit oder im gewissen Kontext angerufen hast und wenn du jetzt in dem Bereich Aktivismus gehst, kannst du ja darüber,
wirklich herausfinden, wer's ähm sozusagen auch tun angehend in der Gruppe oder über wen laufen Netzwerke, über wen verbreiten sich irgendwie Informationen,
hochgradig übergriffig und auch großes Missbrauchspotential, das wird ja immer gesagt, es wird nur,
abgerufen im Bedarfsfall bei begründeten Verdacht ähm und so weiter und dann gibt's vielleicht noch, wird gesagt, ja dann kommen wir ja einen Richter vorbehalt machen,
Hatten wir halt zufällig auch beim AK Vorrat ein paar Leute, die als äh Richter tatsächlich ähm auch,
gearbeitet haben und die meinten so, na ja, also hast du halt einen riesen Papierberg aufm Tisch, ähm ja, kannst du im Detail,
Kapazitäten her beim Einzelfall gucken, gibt's so viele Richter, die ein technisches Verständnis haben, was es eigentlich bedeutet,
schwierig, ne? Und deshalb haben wir gesagt, Demos, Verfassungsbeschwerden, das ist der richtige Weg.
Wie viele Maßnahmen gab's denn da jetzt ein? Also Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist so ein ewiges Thema, ist ja kommt ja jetzt auch gerade wieder.
Es gab die Verfassungsbeschwerde vom Bundesverfassungsgericht.
Gab weiß ich nicht wie viele Urteile auf EU-Ebene?
Und trotzdem 12 Jahre ungefähr später ist es immer noch Thema, ne? Du hast glaube ich jetzt noch Verfahren laufen oder Klagen laufen in dem in dem Gesamtbereich Überwachung oder nicht?
Ja also es gibt halt noch eine größere Verfassungsbeschwerde, wo ähm ziemlich viele Menschen mit an Bord sind, ähm die es halt noch nicht entschieden. Es gab halt unzählige Klagen, also es gab dann halt auch die Kommunikationsanbieter, die gesagt haben so boah, wir haben überhaupt gar keinen Bock, unsere Kunden,
auszuforschen, ähm dann war's ja auch so, dass immer wieder argumentiert wurde, ja ähm Missbrauch von diesen Daten ist nicht bekannt. Es gibt ja andere Länder, die haben das ähm mal zwischendurch implementiert, weil die haben das implementiert, ähm wo dann,
klar war, dass diese Daten dann halt wegen minderschweren Vergehen abgegriffen wurden oder halt sogar um Journalisten auszuforschen, ne. Das wird dann halt ähm einfach,
ignoriert und bei der Strafverfolgung muss man ja sagen, da gibt's halt auch minderschwere Möglichkeiten, ähm wie man ähm halt äh Täter fassen kann, beispielsweise indem man sagt, na ja, das ist halt jemand,
Verdacht da, da gibt's einen begründeten Verdacht, ähm dann guckt sich das ein Richter an und dann sagen wir beispielsweise, okay, da in diesem Fall,
holen wir uns die Daten aber halt nicht von Millionen von Menschen so, ne? Das ist halt der große Unterschied. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, was ist, wenn eine Datenpanne da ist, ne? Dann hast du halt diese Daten im ETA.
Die halt beispielsweise sagen, ähm wer ruft bei welchem Psychologen an. Ähm das ist das wäre ein Riesende.
Wie hat sich denn dieser AK-Vorrat äh so aufgestellt? Also ich meine so ein riesen dezentrale Aktivismusgruppe wo es viele einzelne.
Gibt hat das mit der Konsensfindung für den Aktivismus da gut funktioniert.
War immer wieder eine Herausforderung was aber allerdings wirklich schön war ist wie viele unterschiedliche Menschen da halt wirklich,
zusammengekommen sind, die ähm ganz unterschiedliche Skills reingebracht haben. Ne, also beispielsweise jemand hat gesagt, so ja, ich kann die irgendwie euch einen Wicki aufsetzen und dann war's halt da.
Dann ähm gab's da Leute, die hatten vorher ein bisschen Presseerfahrung, da gab's Leute mit einem unglaublichen juristischen Sachverstand. Also Minart Starostik ähm war jemand, der den AK Vorrat wirklich geprägt hat. Der ist jetzt vor,
einigen Jahren leider verstorben. Also er hat wirklich viele ähm Verfassungsbeschwerden auch im ganzen Bereich Bürgerrechte Datenschutz in den letzten Jahren durchgefor,
ähm erfolgreich durchgefochten und ähm ja dann Leute, die halt schon Demos organisiert haben, ne und ich,
Hat total beeindruckend, wie viel man eigentlich machen kann so als einzelne Person, wenn man mit anderen Leuten zusammenkommt und man alle sagt, so ja, wir schmeißen jetzt Zeit und Skills rein und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert.
Das Schöne oder der Vorteil für den AK-Vorrat war natürlich auch konnte monothematisch sein, ne. Der musste sich jetzt nicht,
zu allem positionieren. Es gab ein gemeinsames Ziel für das oder gegen das man äh sich engagiert hat und man musste sich zu anderen Dingen nicht verhalten.
Ja, wobei man sagen muss, also aus dieser Gruppe sind dann halt natürlich auch andere Dinge so ein bisschen hervorgegangen, beziehungsweise Netzwerke entstanden, wo man dann gesagt hat, so ja okay, jetzt soll,
elektronische Gesundheitskarte kommen, da haben einige Leute gesagt, so oh ja, das ist äh datenschutzmäßig sollten wir da halt auch,
oder beispielsweise bei der Volkszählung ähm ne oder beim elektronischen Entgeltnachweis, der dann ja auch gekippt wurde auch von ähm also,
Man kann sagen, dass es schon monothematisch nach außen war, aber nach innen beispielsweise über die Mailinglisten gab's immer Diskussionen über alle möglichen Datenschutz und Bürgerrecht.
Aber die äh also die Gruppe konnte sich musste sich jetzt nicht mehr.
Zu mehr positionieren. Die konnte sich weiter vernetzen, musste sich nicht weiter verhalten. Ich komme darauf deswegen zu sprechen, weil ihr im weiteren Verlauf dann auch mal bei der Piratenpartei warst, die ja dann doch als Partei gezwungen war, zu allem Möglichen sich zu,
zu positionieren und Positionen aufzubauen, was wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so gut lief, wie im AK-Vorrat.
Es ist natürlich eine ganz andere Sache, wenn du in einer Partei bist als in einer monothematischen Gruppe, auch eine Partei hat ja einfach auch dieses formelle Korsett, was dir vom Gesetzgeber gegeben ist. Das heißt, du musst halt auch so,
keine Ahnung. Du musst halt deine Abrechnung ordentlich machen. Du musst halt äh Aufstellungsversammlung halt auch ein Riesenthema formalistisch, ne? Also das und,
halt mit Leuten, die halt teilweise ja da gab's einige, die hatten halt vorher ähm Parteierfahrungen, aber viele auch nicht,
uns ähm das war halt so learning by doing. Halt manchmal auch mit sehr vielen Schmerzen, also beispielsweise in also ich habe in Niedersachsen war ich äh Landtagskandidatin, ich war später politische Geschäftsführerin der gesamt,
Partei uns, ähm wir hatten beispielsweise eine Aufstellungsversammlung, die musste wiederholt werden, weil da halt formell,
Dinge nicht gut gelaufen sind und das passiert halt wenn du's halt einfach mal machst, ne? Aber ich finde im Zweifel sollte man's lieber halt mal machen und probieren ähm als es zu lassen und für mich war es halt eine,
sehr krasse Erfahrung. Ich war da auch noch ja, es ist halt auch zehn Jahre her, ne. Also ich war da halt auch richtig jung und ähm,
Weiß noch damals bin ich das erste Mal zum Piratenstammtisch damals in Osnabrück hingekommen, meinte so ja ich bin Katha, ich mache was mit Datenschutz, war vorher so beim AK
Vorrat und die so alle ja wir kennen dich schon äh und äh ich so ja ich mag eigentlich keine Parteien und alle nur so nicken.
War auch eine interessante Sache bei so einem ähm ja Parteievent dann und.
Ja, das war schon etwas, was ich nicht vergessen werde, diese Erfahrung. Ich bin mittlerweile nicht mehr Mitglied der Partei. Also ich bin dann irgendwann ausge.
Aber wie blickst du denn auf das Experiment Piratenpartei jetzt äh zurück? Ich meine, er hat sich 2tausendsechs, glaube ich, gegründet. Das äh ist halt also jetzt schon doch 16 Jahre her.
War das die Reise wert.
Total, ne? Also wenn du überlegst, was für Debatten ähm dadurch angestoßen wurden, wie viel Druck auf andere Parteien ausgeübt wurde, Strukturen zu ändern innerparteilich Demokratisierung zu machen, so was wie Transparenzgesetze oder halt auch so Kleinigkeiten, dass halt irgendwie,
Dokumente irgendwie vom ähm also von kommunalen ähm,
Gremien halt irgendwie öffentlich zugänglich sind oder teilweise Livestreaming oder solche Geschichten. Es war ja nicht nur also die Paraden waren in einigen Landtagen, aber was man gerne vergisst, ist, dass wir halt auch auf,
kommunaler Ebene in ziemlich vielen Städten präsent waren,
uns ich würde auf jeden Fall sagen, dass sich was gelohnt hat. Ne, also das so Geschichten sind das beispielsweise die Grünen, sagen wir ähm machen jetzt halt irgendwie wir befragen unsere Mitglieder, wen wir halt wie aufstellen sollen oder wie unser nächster Bundesvorstand,
aussehen soll ähm und machen das nicht nur über Delegierte. Ähm,
wird schon sagen, dass da die Piraten eine große Rolle gespielt haben, was mich halt auch wirklich freut, ist, dass viele Leute, die ich von damals kenne halt ihren Weg gegangen sind, ne, die sind teilweise in andere Parteien gewechselt,
teilweise sind sie halt in den Bereich Aktivismus gegangen und ja wir haben da halt alle auch.
Unsere Erfahrungen gesammelt, ne, also alle waren geil, muss man dazu sagen, aber ähm das Experiment war's auf jeden Fall wert.
Das kann man auf jeden Fall sagen. Gerade so diese diese erste Generation sage ich jetzt mal, Piratenpartei, die da alle bekannt waren mit dir zusammen.
Jetzt nicht auf das alles gleichzeitig war, aber wenn man da jetzt äh Marina Weißband, äh Felix Räder, äh Christopher Lauer, Martin Delius.
Jetzt äh immer noch im Bundestag bei der Linksfraktion parteilos. Ähm da sind schon eine ganze Menge außergewöhnliche Personen.
Gewesen, die auch alle ihren Weg, wie du sagst, weitergegangen sind. Was ich mich was also das würde ich dich gerne mal fragen, meine Hypothese war so ein bisschen, dass die Piratenpartei.
Irgendwann leider überrannt wurde aufgrund ihrer Popularität und dann wahrscheinlich einfach ein ein Haufen Mitglieder angezogen hat,
dann im weiteren Verlauf vielleicht dieses.
Dieses Experiment oder dieses gut gestartete äh diese gut gestartete Bewegung irgendwie in ihren Fängen hatten und kaputt gemacht haben. Durch innere Zerwürfnisse, Widersprüche. Ich hatte wirklich so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass ähm.
Ja auch insbesondere teilweise vorm Spiegel oder von so einem Blog wie Popcorn-Piraten halt wirklich immer wieder auch,
in der Piratenpartei selber die Leute gegeneinander aufgehetzt wurden und dir dieser Streit dann so in der Öffentlichkeit ausgeweidet wurde von vielleicht Journalistinnen, die.
Ja vielleicht auch begeistert waren, dass sie zum ersten Mal die Möglichkeit hatten, so tiefe Einblicke in eine interessante Partei zu bekommen,
Und und das dann irgendwie äh sehr sehr genussvoll auseinandergenommen haben. Würdest du das auch so oder hast du das auch so wahrgenommen oder würdest du sagen es lach an was anderm?
Ich wusste da schon sagen, dass außen Wahrnehmung mit Innenwahrnehmung weit auseinandergehen. Also was ich oft gefragt werde, also was ich auch Jahre später manchmal so,
bei Interviews hinten rumgefragt wurde so ja sag mal ne damals beim Piraten da hast du ja auch mega viel Hass und Streit hinter den Kulissen, das muss ja unglaublich krass für dich gewesen sein muss ich immer sagen so nee.
Habe ich gar nicht erlebt tatsächlich selbst. Also es gab Streit und es gab Konflikte, aber wenn ich das mit anderen Parteien vergleiche, war es nicht außergewöhnlich.
Muss ich sagen ähm,
Es wurde halt öffentlich auf Twitter ausgetragen, ne? Wo man sagen muss, es ist halt heute bei anderen Parteien, also so heute hast du halt beispielsweise Spiegelartikel, irgendwie zwei Bundestagsabgeordnete kacken sich an, das ist halt ja,
jetzt nicht außergewöhnlich, aber damals war's außergewöhnlich, ne? Von daher kann ich halt auch verstehen, dass es natürlich auch ein interessantes Phänomen für einen Journalismus war.
Aber ähm ja ich muss sagen ähm nach innen hin habe ich jetzt nicht erlebt ähm.
Muss ich sagen, dass da die Innen- und Außenwahrnehmung einfach sehr stark auseinandergegangen sind, ne. Also klar, wo es halt angekackt mal von irgendwem, wenn du halt im Bundesvorstand einer Partei bist, aber das ist halt das der Deal, den du dann eingehst, worauf du dich einstellst, ne, also mit,
kommen natürlich auch, dass Leute sagen, so ja hier das war nicht optimal, das da muss man halt umgehen können.
Also Piratenpartei war auf jeden Fall eine politische Konfetti-Kanone, das kann man schon sagen. Das hat ordentlich geknallt. Total war's auch ganz schön bunt. Also es war äh
schmerzhaft mit anzusehen, aber es war insgesamt auf jeden Fall etwas, wo wie du schon gesagt hast, äh was angestoßen wurde, was ich wahrscheinlich jetzt erst,
Jahre später richtig manifestiert durch die Leute, die halt dann dabei bleiben und ihren eigenen Weg gehen.
Würdest du sagen, es war zu früh? Nee, zu früh für ihre Zeit.
Ja, also was heißt zu früh, ne? Also vielleicht hätte man noch früher anfangen können, ne? Ähm ja, aber äh insgesamt so das Thema Datenschutznetz,
äh Transparenz, äh Korruptionsbekämpfung. Ähm die Themen sind ja schon gesetzt worden und haben andere Leute unter Druck gesetzt,
andere Parteien unter Druck gesetzt und man muss ja auch immer sagen, es gibt ja einen anderen Parteien auch Leute, die das Thema schon immer aufm Schirm hatten, die aber einfach nicht gehört wurden.
Und das war indirekt natürlich auch Rückenwind,
für diese Menschen und ich sehe das halt gar nicht so in diesem Parteienkorsett also wie gesagt ich habe damals gesagt Partei ist eigentlich nicht so mein Ding,
ist es nach wie vor nicht und ich muss äh aus ganzem Herzen sagen, mich freut das halt, wenn Leute, die deren Inhalte es gut fand, ähm dann halt plötzlich ähm eine größere Rolle in anderen Parteien beispielsweise bei den Grünen oder bei den Linken.
Oder auch außerhalb der.
Außerhalb, klar.
Also Marina Weißband ist ja mittlerweile.
Aber okay, gut, das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen, aber ich äh habe sie gar nicht so sehr als zumindest in der letzten Zeit, nicht so sehr als politische also als Parteikraft äh erlebt, sondern mehr so als als Person vor allem auch in der Öffentlichkeit, weil sie einfach eine gewisse Bekanntheit auch schon erreicht hat.
Karl. Ja. Wie hast du die Piratenpartei wahrgenommen? Du bist ja jünger als wir.
Es ist halt total krass, weil du meintest so, ja vor zehn Jahren ist da irgendwie aufgestanden. Vor zehn Jahren habe ich halt angefangen irgendwie Netzpolitik wahrzunehmen oder halt habe ich,
angefangen mich aktiv mit äh Computern zu befassen. Deshalb habe ich da so ein bisschen das Glück, dass ich dass ich das Ganze nur so von sehr fern wahrgenommen habe und das eher so,
mich schon Geschichte war, als ich angefangen habe.
Fühle ich mich alt.
Aber ich merke auch, ich merke auch jetzt noch, wie's halt total strahlt und wie viel wie viel halt Networking, wie viel irgendwie Leute, die sich kennen, die zusammen coolen Aktivismus auch jetzt noch machen,
aus derzeit bestehen und da kommen wir später auch noch drauf auf zur Forschung, hat da einige ähm Connection, die irgendwie Piraten basiert sind.
Also du für dich war das alles schon Geschichte. Ja das ist überhaupt nicht verletzend jetzt für uns ähm weiter mit Katharina. Ja mach mal.
Aber man muss ja sagen, also die Piraten haben ja tatsächlich noch ähm einen Abgeordneten im es halt auch unglaublich lange kenne, nämlich vom AK Vorrat ähm Doktor Patrick Breyer halt auch äh Jurist, Richter an zahlreichen Verfassungsbeschwerden.
Mit beteiligt und ich muss sagen allein dass ähm jemand wie er ähm halt in einem Parlament sitzt äh dafür hat sich äh die ganze Geschichte gelohnt muss ich sagen, ne, weil es halt ähm jemand ist, für den ich wirklich meine Hand ins Feuer legen,
im Bereich äh Datenschutz gibt und das gibt's ja gerade auch diverse Debatten auf europäischer Ebene, ähm Chatkontrolle, ne, also.
Staatenhals äh übergriffigerweise auf ähm,
Kommunikationsdaten, ähm Kommunikationsdaten zugreifen und da jemanden einfach zu sitzen zu haben, der an dem Thema halt schon viele, viele Jahre dran ist.
Finde ich so krass, weil Patrick derzeit Jahren,
mit dieser Chatkontrolle dran. Sagt immer, Leute, da kommt was, Chatkontrolle aufpasst, der hat die Domain schon seit Jahren und denkst immer so, Junge, ich ich.
Ganz viele, dumme Menschen.
Ja ich ich sehe es irgendwie nicht. Das ist doch völliger Irrsinn, was sie sich da ausgedacht haben. Damit kommen wir doch nie durch und er dachte so, ja doch, ihr müsst da mal gucken. Zack, irgendwann kommt der Zug eingefahren, reißt alles mit und er hat er hat wirklich seit Jahren ist er nimmt.
Ihr hattet den auch letztens in der.
Ja, also wir müssen einfach mal gucken, welche Domains er eigentlich noch so registriert hat, um sozusagen die Themen für die nächste Dekade.
Bescheid, aber du hast schon recht. Also der, was bei ihm halt fasziniert ist, ist, dass er in einer absoluten Tiefe und auch gewissermaßen mit einer Ruhe,
an dieser an diesen Verzweiflungsthemen dran ist, die da von EU-Ebene auf uns zurollen,
sich da äh ja da einfach auch nicht äh nicht aufgibt da dran zu bleiben.
Bisschen noch. Was zu sagen.
Nee, sie hatte Patrick jetzt auch schon gelobt. Kommen wir mal zum.
Genau, weil wir wollen ja eigentlich über das reden, was du auch äh jetzt machst, weil mittlerweile gehst du ja als Autorin äh durch würde ich sagen, also wenn man so ein Einblender braucht Katharina Nugrun, Autorin, oder?
Also das ist das, was ich mache. Ich ähm habe äh vier Bücher geschrieben, wobei das äh vierte noch kommt. Das kommt im Herbst und ähm ja, das ist das, was ich hauptsächlich grad so mache.
Genau, das erster hieß die Daten, die ich rief? Ja. Und da hast du wahrscheinlich erstmal so deine ganze Erfahrung, von der wir jetzt gerade schon gesprochen haben, eingebracht.
Genau, also vor allem diesen Frust, wenn man sagt irgendwie so ja, was machst du? Dann sagt man so, ja, was mit äh Datenschutz und dann kommt einem immer so, ja, also ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen und dann dachte ich so ja okay,
Mal ausführlich auf, warum wir alle etwas zu verbergen haben und warum's vielleicht auch nicht so um dich als Person geht, sondern eher um eine Frage von,
Solidarität, ne? Also wollen wir in einer Gesellschaft leben, wo wir von jedem verlangen, nichts zu verbergen haben zu wollen. Es gibt ja vulnerable Gruppen, es gibt gute Gründe,
seine Gesundheit mit seinen Gesundheitsdaten nicht hausieren gehen zu wollen, geht ja dann nicht nur um die eigenen Daten bei Erbkrankheiten, um die Daten der Kinder und so weiter und so fort.
Da habe ich's halt ein Buch geschrieben, wo ich mir die Frage gestellt habe, wie erkläre ich das eigentlich Leuten, warum mich das beschäftigt und ich dachte, der beste Ansatz ist eigentlich mal zu schauen,
wie so ein konkreter Datenschatten aussieht. Das heißt, es gibt ähm es gab schon damals ähm unter dem also,
Bundesdatenschutzgesetz die Möglichkeit kostenlos seine Daten abzufragen, das heißt du kannst jederzeit äh als Kunde zu einem Dienst gehen und sagen so hallo, ihr habt sicher schon lange auf mich gewartet, hier ist folgender,
auf denen ich mich berufe. Ähm ich hätte gerne eine kostenlose Kopie meiner Daten und dann müssen sie dir das aushändigen. Ne, also,
In der Theorie natürlich besser als in der Praxis. In der Praxis hat man dann eine längere Brieffreundschaft, aber ähm man kriegt da am Ende schon sehr interessante Daten raus. Ähm unter anderem,
Ähm so bei der Deutschlandkarte, bei diesem Rabattprogramm, mal geschaut, ähm ja können also wird der erfasst, was für einzelne Produkte ich kaufe, an,
ja ähm und bei Amazon habe ich mal geschaut, wie sieht eigentlich so ein ähm Klickstream aus und das habe ich dann mit einer ähm professionellen Datenanalystin,
Katja Dittrich auch als Letti bekannt, ähm die hat mir das dann aufgedröselt, weil das waren dann halt unglaubliche Datenmengen, also man muss sagen, das ist nicht nur, was ich bei Amazon gekauft habe, sondern jedes Mal, wenn ich,
Amazon eingeloggt mir anschaue, dann halt wirklich jeder Klick, ne? Und äh jedes Produkt, was ich mir angeschaut habe, jede Bewertung, ähm alles.
Und daraus kannst du halt ein wunderschönes Daten- und Interessensprofil machen. Sah bei mir halt auch so ein bisschen abartig aus, weil ich ähm zu der Zeit halt auch,
iel mir angeschaut habe, ähm was für rechtsextreme Autoren gibt's eigentlich so bei,
Amazon von da anhand des Datenprofils konnte man mich schon für eine ziemlich ähm komische Person haben, ne? Ähm Fun Fact am Rande, ähm ich habe das als,
CD dann zugeschickt bekommen, auch nach einer mehrmonatigen Brieffreundschaft erst mal,
Und die erste CD ist halt auch in der Post verloren gegangen. Ich weiß bis heute nicht, wo die ist. Also von daher immer, wenn ihr so ähm Datenauskünfte anfordert, äh ist halt ganz geil, wenn die,
sind. Man man weiß ja nie.
Dann hast du dich als nächstes und das war wahrscheinlich schon deine Recherche, wenn du sagst, du hast ja die ganzen Naziautoren recherchiert. Dein nächstes Buch zusammen mit Pia Lamberti war Fake-Fact.
Genau. Ja also da muss man noch zwischenschalten. Ähm es hat ein ähm also meine Familie hat einen Migrationshintergrund. Äh wir kommen aus Polen und äh dementsprechend äh ist mein Verhältnis zur AfD,
uns ähm ja ich habe eine Zeit lang in meinem Blog halt so die Wahlprogramme der AFD analysiert um transparent zu machen was für ein Quatsch da drin steht und das ist dann halt viral gegangen was zur Folge hatte, dass ich sehr viel Fan.
Bekommen habe, wo dann halt irgendwie ähm sehr offensichtlich war, dass ich dann in diverse Verschwörungserzählungen eingebaut wurde, also da haben irgendwie Leute gestimmt, so ja, irgendwie,
dass du damals diese Soli ähm Aktion oder Demos Solidarität gemacht hast, aber du wirst doch jetzt von der jüdischen Welt erlitten
bezahlt so. Du musst das schreiben. Ach, du bist das. Ja genau, ich bin das und ähm es hört sich jetzt so lustig an, aber ich war halt auch wirklich mit irgendwie äh Todeslisten und ähm das sollte mir geschrieben haben, wir ähm machen dich kalt und so,
du gehörst ins KZ, du bist eigentlich Jüdin und das war dann halt für mich schon ähm ja so ein Punkt.
Wo mir klar wurde, was was für eine große Rolle Verschwörungserzählung eigentlich auch für rechtsextreme Radikalisierungen,
bedeuten, ne und wie einfach man da halt selber auch reinrutschen kann als ja Opfer eigentlich, ne und,
Pia Lamberti ähm ist Sozialpsychologin und forscht seit vielen Jahren zu der Frage, warum glauben Menschen eigentlich an Verschwörungsideologien und dann,
habe ich sie besucht bei einem Forschungsaufenthalt im Ausland und dann sind wir durch die Wüste gewandert und dann kam so die Idee, ja lass mal unsere,
Kompetenzen zusammenschmeißen und ähm Buch zusammen schreiben und wir hätten niemals gedacht, dass dieses Buch dann inmitten einer Pandemie rauskommt, wo dann halt Platz ist in Berlin.
Und zehntausende äh Leute mit komischen Plakaten ähm rumstehen und ähm ja das mit der Bedrohungslage in Bezug auf die eigene Person wird dann halt auch noch mal deutlich krasser, weil wir dann
beide natürlich auch feindbild für diese Szene waren,
weil wir äh in dem Buch uns sehr kritisch natürlich mit diesem Phänomen beschäftigt haben und auch sehr klar gemacht haben, so hey diese Bezüge zu Rechtsextremismus, die gab's schon immer. Ja also selbst wenn du sagst so ha also eine Standardfrage war.
Journalistinnen und Journalisten halt auch oft. Was ist denn die lustigste Verschwörungserzählung so? Was ne am Ende des Interviews nochmal so irgendwie was was fröhliches,
fast den Eindruck, da muss man sagen so na ja, also selbst wenn man sich die Leute anschaut, die irgendwie ein außerirdischer Echsenmenschen,
glauben, ähm im im Endeffekt ist das eine Entmenschlichung dieser Person nach dem Motto, auch wenn ich einen Anschlag auf die ausübe, das ist ja nicht mal ein Mensch, sondern das ist ein Alien. Und ähm da gibt's sehr starke Antisemitismusbezüge.
So richtig lustig ist, also äh.
Kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen, wenn man so mal drauf blickt, da sind wirklich lustige Sachen bei, aber die treiben das halt leider in eine Richtung, die dann wirklich überhaupt nicht mehr witzig ist und,
wie sagt äh ich weiß gar nicht, wer wo der woher der Satz kommt, aber wer einen Scheiß glaubt glaubt auch den nächsten Scheiß.
Ist tatsächlich. Also es ist wirklich ein Sog, ne. Also die Leute kommen wegen einer äh irgendeiner Geschichte oder,
ähm in solche Milieus rein und sie werden konstant gefüttert mit äh Sachen, die halt immer weitergehen, ne. Also das äh wenn man sich länger diese Telegram-Gruppen anschaut,
merkt man sehr schnell, wohin die Reise geht, ne. Also es ist halt Esoterik äh gepaart mit ähm Verschwörungs,
Glaube zu zum Thema Corona und dann hast du ein paar Reichsbürger-Posts dazwischen. Keiner findet das problematisch, der da ist, ne? Und dann wird immer gesagt, ja wir sind für Meinungsfreiheit gegen Zensur, wenn du einen Faktencheck postest, bist du raus. Ja, dann wirst du sofort halt,
bei vielen Gruppe.
Ähm da spielen natürlich Online-Plattformen auch eine Rolle, weil ähm es schon seit Jahren diese Kritiker vor Corona Riesendiskussion inwiefern nicht diese Vorschlagsalgorithmen beispielsweise bei YouTube,
aber auch Feed Algorithmen wie ähm also bei Facebook, ähm aber auch Instagram,
die das nicht befeuern. Ja und wenn man sagt, wenn man sich neuere Netzwerke anschaut, wie beispielsweise TikTok,
wo es wirklich darum geht, dass man den nächsten Contact vorgeschlagen bekommt und analysiert wird, wie schnell wische ich das weg, je nachdem, wer nicht in eine andere Richtung gelenkt,
Das ist keine kleine Frage, sondern Plattformen haben da schon eine ziemlich große Macht.
Wie würdest du denn und das ist, glaube ich, was ihr dann im mit dem nächsten Buch äh versucht habt.
Also im ersten Buch erklären, okay, wie wie funktionieren diese Denkströme? Warum funktioniert das überhaupt und was gibt's da und wohin führt das? Und dann ist aber natürlich die Frage, okay, was machen wir jetzt dagegen?
Ja so ähm es gab halt ähnlich muss ich sagen wie bei der ganzen Pegida-Debatte ja auch immer wieder diese ähm Stimmen, die in der Öffentlichkeit gesagt haben, so ja, wir müssen,
den Leuten reden und dann lass doch in die Talksendung einladen und dann gewinnt das bessere Argument und dann muss man sagen so na ja da haben wir schon sehr schlechte Erfahrungen beim Thema Klimawandelleugnung gemacht,
Ähm das ist so eine Falsebalance, ja unbedarfte Zuschauer, der sich das anschaut, ähm denkt sich dann so, ja, die Wahrheit,
in der Mitte liegen, ähm ist dann vollkommen falscher Eindruck, muss man sagen,
gleichzeitig muss man sagen, dass bei Menschen, die vollkommen in diesen Weltbildern drin sind, ähm da kommt man kaum noch mit Argumenten durch. Ja, also wie will man mit jemandem diskutieren, der sagt, die Wissenschaft als Ganzes?
Ist Teil einer Verschwörung. Da kann man ja gar nicht mehr mit wissenschaftlichen Studien beispielsweise zum Thema ähm Corona argumentieren oder zum Thema Impfung argumentieren. Ähm.
Checks kommen bei so Leuten kaum noch an, weil sie eben sagen, na ja, die Faktenchecker, die die sind natürlich auch Teil der Verschwörung, ne. Also für die Leute, wie gesagt, Pia und ich sind ähm ja auch mit Teil äh von irgendwelchen Netzwerken, wahlweise alles Mögliche.
Uns ähm in solchen Fällen ist eigentlich oftmals das private Umfeld ähm so die letzten Leute, die halt überhaupt noch irgendwie durch,
weil man eben so eine Vertrauensbasis hat, wo man sagt, so na ja, ich vertraue den Medien nicht, in Anführungsstrichen den Medien.
Oder halt ja Wissenschaftlerinnen, Wissenschaftlern aber irgendwie mit meiner Schwester und da höre ich noch zu, wenn sie mir was sagt,
Da haben wir eben ähm nach dem gemeinsamen ersten Buch halt noch einen Ratgeber ähm gemeinsam geschrieben,
eben gezielt auch mit Beratungsstellen ähm gesprochen haben und gefragt haben, so wie gehe ich denn damit um? Ne, aber auch ganz klar gesagt haben, sind da ja auf privater Ebene, wenn das,
ist, man macht sich ja auch Sorgen im grade im Gesundheitsbereich, ne, weil die Leute dann halt auch wirklich problematische Entscheidungen treffen. Man,
halt immer so, na ja, das ist ein Corona-Thema und wenn Corona vielleicht eines Tages nicht mehr Thema ist, dann ist es nicht mehr wichtig, aber.
Eben immer wieder diese Geschichten, dass Leute in diese Szenen reinkommen, ähm gesund sind, dann denkt man, ja, ist halt okay, mach was du willst, dann nimm halt Zucker, wenn du irgendwie erkältet bist,
meinetwegen hilft der Placebo-Effekt, aber dann, wenn sie eines Tages Krebs bekommen und dann wieder auf,
esoterischen Produkte setzen oder das, was ihnen bei Telegram beworben wird oder sogar Chlorbleiche trinken, das ist auch ein Riesenthema auf Telegram. Ähm dann können sie wirklich daran sterben. Ne und deshalb muss man sagen, je früher man interveniert, gerade bei Gesundheitsthemen, desto besser.
Ähm da wollten wir eben Menschen was an die Hand geben, die sagen so ja, ich möchte diesen Kampf kämpfen, wobei wir auch gleichzeitig sagen, es ist absolut legitimer an irgendeinem Punkt, zu sagen so ja, das ist.
Überschreitet für mich eine Schwelle, beispielsweise bei Antisemitismus, Rassismus, das darf man nicht einfach wegschweigen, sondern muss das ansprechen und ich persönlich würde meinen Weihnachten auch nicht mit einem Reichsbürger am Tisch verbringen wollen, Punkt.
Obwohl du jetzt auch zu den Echsenmenschen gehörst.
Ja, ne, also es ähm muss man sagen, ähm ist halt leider leider nicht lustig so in in diesem Milieus ähm als Teil einer Exmenschenverschwörung gesehen zu werden, ne also es ist.
Ich weiß noch, ich muss jetzt nicht mehr äh Kalauer zu machen, ja. Dein nächstes Projekt, das letzte Buch, äh was du schon angesprochen hast, läuft unter dem Titel gefährlicher Glaube?
Genau, gefährlichster Glaube, Untertitel ist die radikale Gedankenwelt der Esoterik. Hintergrund ist, dass wir im Zuge unserer Recherche ähm einfach auch, dass es sehr offensichtlich es gibt, eine große Überschneidung, gerade bei Gesundheitsthemen,
Esoterik und Verschwörungsglaube, weil eben Esoteriker oftmals,
mit einer angeblichen Verschwörung in Medizin oder Wissenschaft argumentieren, um halt ihre.
So nach dem Motto ähm ja natürlich habe ich keine Studien um zu zeigen, dass irgendwie mein Zauberstein, dein Rheuma heilt, ähm aber die Pharmalobby möchte das ja unter,
Waren auch ähm beim also ja bei der Recherche unseres ersten Buchs, bei so einer Esoterikmesse. Da wurde Fazit tatsächlich halt so rosa Steinchen gegen ähm Krebs,
ne und dann bist hingegangen, habe halt gelogen und habe gesagt, so ja irgendwie meine jemand aus meiner Familie hat halt Krebs.
Der wollte mir eiskalte Steine verkaufen. Da meinte sie, ja ist halt schon schlimm. Da meinte er so, ja dann muss man die halt länger unters Kopfkissen legen. So und das war halt echt brutal,
uns ja, also Esoterik hat halt große Überschneidung, was vielen Leuten auch nicht klar ist, ist, dass es so etwas wie braune Esoterik gibt. Ähm das heißt, es gibt ähm ja also.
Im Esoterikbereich Leute, die sich A nicht äh von rechts abgrenzen oder B ähm sogar offen antisemitisch sind, ne, also beispielsweise dieses so,
zu Nazizeiten, wo teils behauptet ist, äh man also die es gäbe eine verjudete Schulmedizin,
Finde ich den Begriff auch hochproblematisch und wird den nicht äh verwenden und.
Teile dieser Narrative findet man immer noch heute in der Esoterikszene wieder. Ne und das ist ja auch auf dem sogenannten Coronademos auch sehr offensichtlich, dass es Esoterik da eine große Rolle spielt.
Glaubst du diese Leute, die auf diesen Messen sind und diese Steinchen verkaufen? Die glauben das oder sind das äh Betrügerinnen und Betrüger?
Teils teils äh von außen kann man das im Einzelfall ähm nicht immer sagen, ne? So ähnlich wie beim Thema Verschwörungsglaube, es gibt,
Akteure wie beispielsweise Alex Jones, das ist ein US-amerikanischer Verschwörungsideologe, der hat wirklich ein Medienimperium aufgebaut. Der verkauft halt auch in seinem ähm Shop halt irgendwelche Vitaminpillen, die man angeblich braucht, um irgendwie,
wachzudenken und alles zu durchschauen, ähm auch Zubehör, falls der nächste Bürgerkrieg ausbricht, wie beispielsweise,
kugelsichere Laptoptasche. Wer meint, so etwas zu brauchen uns ähm im Esoterikumfeld lässt sich unglaublich viel Geld äh mit Gesundheitsthemen.
Also machen, ne und im Einzelfall finde ich, ist es für den Betroffenen recht egal, ob derjenige überzeugt davon ist, dass es wirkt oder ob er sagt, so ja ist mir egal, Haupt.
Geld, weil es auf dasselbe hinausläuft. Ähm ja, also ich würde sagen, teils teils. Aber viele sind tatsächlich wirklich selber auch überzeugt. Ne, also nehmen das Zeug auch selbst.
Ja weil es ich meine, wenn sie genug Kunden haben, werden einige dieser Kundinnen und Kunden sicherlich auch Verkäuferinnen werden. Ich frage mich nur.
Auch so ein Multilevel Marketing ist auch ein großes Ding in der Szene dass du beispielsweise zu einem Workshop gehst und dann sagen die Leute so ja du kannst halt auch selbst erleuchtet werden. Du kannst halt diesen,
Zertifikat machen und dann wirst du halt selber Anbieter und ähm verkaufst dann eben auch selbst diese Produkte. Das heißt, du hängst auch irgendwo,
da mit drin auch so Pyramidensysteme gibt's auch in der Szene ja also teilweise werden da Leute auch in den Ruin getrieben oder machen sich eben auch mit zu Komplizen ne? Aber glauben halt gleichzeitig selber daran sie würden Leuten helfen.
Diesen Glauben, also was ich sicherlich nicht für für alles eine Erklärung, aber was ich auch oft so wahrgenommen habe, ist, dass diese Absurdität dieser Annahmen, die dort äh verbreitet werden oder geglaubt werden,
auch oft ähm Ausdruck so eines Wunsches ist zu so einer Gruppe dazuzugehören. Nach dem Motto.
Glaube jetzt hier einfach mal an diesen Scheiß, obwohl er totaler Unsinn ist und dadurch zeige ich quasi meine Zugehörigkeit,
in diese in dieser Gruppe. So, ich bin bereit.
Jeden Scheiß äh nach zu äh erzählen und zu glauben und deswegen fühle ich mich dann angenommen und habe da sozusagen auch ein soziales Umfeld für mich erschaffen.
Man hat natürlich, also es gibt da gibt es halt tatsächlich sehr starke Ähnlichkeiten zwischen Verschwörungsglaube und Esoterik. Du hast halt das Gefühl, du bist einer der wenigen, die den Durchblick haben. Du bist einer der wenigen, die erleuchtet sind sozusagen.
Habe ich auch.
Ja schön, äh möchtest du einen Heilstein kaufen? Ich habe noch welche dabei. Nein, ähm Spaß beiseite. Ähm ist ja tatsächlich auch ein
sehr ernstes Thema, ähm aber dieses ähm auch diese Illusion, die Kontrolle über diese Situation zu haben, kann auch eine Rolle spielen, ne. Also man hat was also es gibt beispielsweise die Studien, die zeigen,
sogenanntes magisches Denken ähm eher ausgeprägt war, also bei einem untersuchten Fall in Regionen, die ähm stark,
Konflikten gebeutelt waren im Vergleich zu anderen Regionen. Das heißt, es kann sein, dass einige Leute,
so diese Illusion schaffen. Ich kann selber meine Umwelt, wo ich irgendwelche magischen Rituale beeinflussen, weil mir das ja Sicherheit gibt. Ne, also ist halt,
besser zu ertragen für einige Leute aus als Chaos und das ähm ist halt eben nicht auch beim,
Verschwörungsglaube, weil man hat das Gefühl na ja, der Plan ist nicht schön, den es da gibt, aber zumindest gibt es einen Plan und ich kenne ihn und ich bin einer der wenigen, die Bescheid weiß. Und natürlich.
So auf emotionaler Ebene ist das eine einfache Geschichte. Es gibt die,
es gibt die Bösen beim Verschwörungsnamen. Also die Verschwörer und die, die dagegen kämpfen, das sind automatisch die Guten, du wertest dich auf, ne? Das ist auch eine Heldengeschichte und bei der Esoterik, glaubst du,
kämpfst halt sozusagen auf der Seite des Lichts, ne, gegen die Seite der Dunkelheit. Das ist halt eben auch so ein,
was oftmals äh benutzt wird und das ist natürlich eine viel einfachere Geschichte als zu sagen, naja die Welt ist super kompliziert, ne und vieles, was passiert, passiert vielleicht aus Zufall, nicht mit Absicht ähm gerade im politischen Bereich, Inkompetenz spielt eine sehr große Rolle, würde ich sagen.
Ähm ja stattdessen hast du halt diese ja Hollywood Geschichten kann man fast sagen ne.
Würdest du äh auch oder würdest du zustimmen oder habt ihr Belege dafür gefunden, dass sage ich mal so ein Glaube an Verschwörungsmythen oder ähm.
Vielleicht esoterik ist wahrscheinlich zu zu niederschwellig oder zu schwer zu erfassen. Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass,
Das ist bei Menschen verbreitet ist, die in irgendeiner Form eine traumatische Erfahrung hatten. Also ich weiß gar nicht, das, was wir unbedingt als Trauma ähm bezeichnen, aber.
Die Wende.
Ein Land, ein Staat, äh alles woran du geglaubt hast, existiert vom einen auf den anderen Tag nicht mehr und alles um dich herum ist neu, ne. Du musst eine komplett neue Gesellschaft lernen, weil dein äh das Land, in dem du aufgewachsen bist, auf einmal nicht mehr existiert und jetzt andere,
andere Fahnen und Venen und andere Gesetze ähm gelten und die Karriere, auf die du gesetzt hast, jetzt auf einmal nix mehr wert ist,
oder eine Pandemie, die viele Menschen an die Grenzen dessen bringt, wo worauf sie sich mit dem Leben vorbereitet haben.
Das in die Richtung, was du gerade sagtest, dass bei dass es oder in kriegerischen Bereichen, das ist ja ehnlich, ist ja auch ein absolutes Trauma, was alles was man an Sicherheit und Sonstigem hatte, plötzlich weg ist,
ist das ein Nährboden im weitesten Sinne dafür.
Also beim Thema Verschwörungsglauben gibt's tatsächlich Studien, die zeigen, dass Menschen in Kontrollverlustsituationen anfälliger werden für solche Geschichten,
Es gibt Studien, die wirklich zeigen, dass ähm Menschen mit einer hohen Verschwörungsmentalität, die dann so gemessen wird mit Standard,
Fragebögen, dass die auch ähm eher dazu neigen, Muster zu sehen, wo keine sind, ne. Also das ähm wurde halt in der Studie abgefragt, indem man, also wir kennen das vielleicht,
Augenarzt, wenn wir hingehen und der testet, ob wir halt irgendwie gut Farben sehen können, dann sieht man so Pixelmuster, man muss nur sagen,
man da halt ein Bild, ne und dann hat man denen ganz viele von diesen äh Pixelbildern gezeigt und gesagt, so ja, irgendwo sind hier Grafiken versteckt. Äh kannst du sagen, wo,
ähm ja Menschen mit einer hohen Verschwörungsmentalität haben dazu geneigt, äh Muster zu sehen, wo keine waren. Also die haben dann halt eher sich etwas so zusammen.
Beim Thema Esoterik mit ähm ja also es gibt Einzelstudien, die haben sich das beispielsweise in Konfliktregionen das Ganze angeschaut,
Muss aber sagen jetzt äh im speziellen Fall Wende ist es tatsächlich so, dass da vorher in den Neunzigern im Westen tatsächlich Esoterik richtig dick war, also,
War halt auch so eine Sache, ähm wo Pia und ich lange drüber diskutiert haben, unsere Kindheitserinnerung, ne? Also ich weiß nicht, ob wir noch diese sogenannten Mädchenzeitschriften kennt,
man dann halt irgendwie so ein so ein äh Kraftarmband hatte oder dann wurde halt irgendwie so Anleitung pendeln oder Liebeszauber. Das wurde halt total harmlos dargestellt,
Und da ist der Esoterik Trend tatsächlich eher in den Osten übergeschwappt und man muss auch sagen, dass damals teilweise gezielt äh sektenähnliche Gruppierungen ähm halt auch in unterschiedlich also beispielsweise nach Polen, Russland hingegangen sind.
Weil sie gesehen haben, naja okay im im Westen es hat teilweise schon äh Gerichtsverfahren anhänglich gegen uns ist nicht mehr ganz so einfach,
Man hat versucht sozusagen neue Märkte zu erschließen, ja. Also da sind wirklich gezielt beispielsweise die sogenannte Vereinigungskirche. Das ist eine ähm ja sektenähnliche Gruppierung, die so aus Südkorea ursprünglich kommt, die eine Zeit lang auch,
In den USA ähm größer war, diesen gezielt nach Russland hingegangen und haben beispielsweise gesagt, wir machen jetzt so Kultur aus.
Mit Studierenden und dann kriegen die halt ähm so gratis Fahrt,
in die USA und zufällig reden wir halt die ganze Zeit über unseren Guru und äh ja versuchen Leute zu.
Hast du dich so viel damit auseinandergesetzt? Kannst du uns allen noch einen Tipp mitgeben, wie wir dieses Problem loswerden, weil das ist also eine Verschwörungsmythen, Esoterik, also.
Man kann ja wirklich über viel auch diskutieren an an gesellschaftlichen Herausforderungen, aber wenn Menschen sich wirklich ja der.
Der Erkenntnistheorie verweigern oder eine andere äh anwenden.
Kannst du ja über nichts mehr mit denen reden, ne? Also wenn und das auch tatsächlich das, was mir jetzt grade mit dieser äh Coronapandemie so Sorgen macht, dass da ja wirklich eine ganze Reihe oder scheinbar neue.
Ausbrüche von.
Äh ja Verschwörungsglaube äh da waren, vielleicht ähm du wirst es besser wissen, waren die eh schon immer da, die haben nur die neue Situation jetzt gehabt.
Aber kriegen wir die irgendwie in Griff? Kann man also haben wir irgendeinen Ausblick nach vorne, was man dass man,
über die Bildung machen oder oder können wir den vielleicht vielleicht über Chemtrails kriegen wir die vielleicht über Chemtrails in Griff oder so aber irgendwas müssen wir ja mit denen machen.
Ich glaube, das Wichtigste ist halt, Leuten wirklich mitzugeben, ähm nehmt das ernst, ne. Also wenn ihr jemanden im Umfeld habt, äh der so komische Dinge von sich gibt, ähm je früher ihr interveniert, desto größer ist die Chance,wohl bei Esoterik als auch,
Verschwörungsglauben, ne. Also wie gesagt, wenn's halt äh so ist, dass man plötzlich in einer Pandemie ist, ne? Oder halt die Person beispielsweise Krebs hat und dann noch Heilsteine setzt, dann in der Situation, wenn jemand schon Jahre in diesem Milieu ist, ist es super schwierig, ne?
Ähm von daher ja, wenn jemand äh,
komischen Links äh um die Ecke kommt oder beim Familienessen komisch abdriftet ähm je früher ihr was sagt ähm desto größer ist die Chance, dass ihr eigentlich auch keine große anstrengende Diskussion habt,
jemanden da wirklich schnell rausholen.
Wäret den Anfängen sozusagen. Super Kata.
Genau. Sorry, war halt nicht unterhaltsam und lustig, das tut mir sehr leid.
Tickst auf jeden Fall die Box super informativ und wichtig und das äh deswegen haben wir dich ja auch eingeladen.
Unsere Sendung ist nie lustig, nie wirklich lustig. Ich habe ich habe.
Leider das angekündigte äh Brunen-Yoga jetzt gar nicht angesprochen im Vorgespräch. Ja, wir haben über braune Esoterik gesprochen, wir haben uns angesprochen, dass es in den 1920er Jahren tatsächlich wohnen äh Yoga äh gab. Das kam so aus dem,
Umfeld der Ario Sophie so rechtsextreme Esoterik und das wurde auch nackt.
Das machen wir dann nach der Sendung. Ja.
Da kann ich wenigstens noch den Reiz verstehen, ja, aber das.
Oh Mann, na gut vielen Dank Katar. Jetzt müssen wir aber genau den Applaus einsammeln hier.
Dein dein fünftes Buch ist noch nicht in Planung oder kannst du kannst du uns schon mal sagen, mit wem du dich als nächstes.
Da machst du aber was mehr als so ein Uplifting-Thema oder?
Ey wisst ihr was? Ich freue mich total drauf, ein Jahr ohne Buch zu haben gerade.
Es schlagen ja auch ein paar Themen vor. So Karl.
Hallöchen.
Ich sehe schon, du hast ja noch rosa Plüschpulli noch zugelegt, wird ein bisschen frischer hier auf der Bühne.
So besser? Ja es äh es wird wirklich frisch. Also gerade prallte hier noch die Sonne aufs Zelt, aber jetzt jetzt zieht es vorbei.
Ja du bist äh was war das?
Schilderndes Internet schilderndes Interneteinhorn.
Da muss ich echt mal einsteigen, weil äh das Einhorn hat äh in in in der äh erweiterten Computerszene in den letzten Jahren irgendwie eine äh erhöhte Popularität äh erfahren, habe ich so den Eindruck. Wofür steht es deiner Auffassung nach.
Oh gute Frage, ich glaube einfach halt so um alles sein können, alles sein, glitzern, auch immer immer gut und wichtig und halt einfach sich selbst zu sein.
Einhörner haben auch in den in diesen Esoterik-Zeitschriften für junge Frauen eine Rolle gespielt, oder?
Eventuell ja.
Damit habe ich nichts zu tun. Das war ich nicht. Das war vor meiner Zeit, auch ein Kraftarmband.
Das darf nicht schnell nachgeschaut, was die mir hier am Eingang gegeben haben. Nee, da ist ein strahlender Chip dran, das äh ich sage, hier ist die Impfung.
Gut ähm Karl, du bist ähm hackend äh unterwegs und äh wir haben's ja schon rausgearbeitet äh jünger als wir.
Ähm ein ganzes Stück wahrscheinlich ja.
So war das nicht gemein. Danke.
Wie ich vorhin schon meinte, also als äh du vor zehn Jahren bei den Piraten irgendwie oder wahrscheinlich deutlich länger oder ihr vor zehn Jahren diesen Podcast angefangen habt, äh da bin ich gerade zum ersten Mal bei angekommen noch als als ganz ganz kleines Karl und ähm,
Meine Mutter irgendwie hingeschickt hat, weil sie meinte, ach du du magst doch das mit den Computern? Ich hatte mich schon immer so,
Schule so ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, geh da doch mal hin und mach das mal und ähm wie wahrscheinlich viele, die mal bei jugendhaft waren, ob jetzt als Mentor innen oder eben auch als äh Teilnehmende,
ähm gemerkt haben zieht einen das doch ganz schön in den Bann und man äh kommt da nicht so schnell wieder raus.
Ich bin jetzt ehrlich gesagt schon fast überrascht, dass es schon wieder zehn Jahre alt ist.
Kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass ich schon seit.
War das erste. Jahre. Okay, neun.
Ich glaube bei der ersten erzähl doch mal kurz für die Leute, die nicht wissen, was Jugend hackt ist, was Jugend hackt äh und was äh das mit dir gemacht hat.
Jugend hackt es ein Programm für Jugendliche wie der Name vermuten lässt so ein bisschen in der Reihe von Jugend forscht, jung musiziert, jung diskutiert oder so,
wo es darum geht Jugendlichen die vielleicht schon ein Technikinteresse haben oder zumindest irgendwie sich damit beschäftigen wollen den Raum dafür zu geben, das ist dann,
meistens im Format von so einem Wochenende Heckesson, wo die Jugendlichen ankommen,
selber Ideen entwerfen, also inzwischen bin ich nicht mehr jugendlich so jung bin ich dann doch nicht, sondern ähm Mentor in,
ähm wir geben denen irgendwie den Raum, wir helfen ihnen dabei, Ideen zu entwickeln, zu brainstormen, aber alles kommt von den Jugendlichen und dann haben sie ein Wochenende Zeit, die den umzusetzen und,
jedes Mal entstehen da unfassbar großartige Projekte, richtig krasse Ideen, die mich jedes Mal total flashen,
und ähm halt auch so ein bisschen das Feuer in den Jugendlichen hoffentlich entfacht. Also du hast auch ein bisschen Karriere gemacht, ne? Also am Anfang war's so einfach ein normaler Teilnehmer, aber nicht mehr, weil ich zu alt bin. Ja. Ach so.
Das ist multi-level Marketing du kannst ein paar Mal mitmachen und dann musst du anfangen selber die trainieren.
Bis 18 ist äh die Zielgruppe für die Teilnehmenden und danach muss man halt ich glaube davor darf man noch nicht Mentorin sein.
Okay, also Mentorin heißt, äh man man ist dann quasi Teil dieses äh Workshops, aber quasi auf der anderen Seite und wenn dann die äh Kids kommen und sagen, hm ja ich würde aber gerne oder ich kann das, ich kann das oder ich habe noch keine Idee, dass man wirft Ideen rein oder man.
Ideen machen die komplett selber, da da dürfen wir nichts äh nichts mitmachen. Also wir dürfen natürlich so ein bisschen lenken, aber die Ideen kommen auch immer in äh großen Mengen von den Jugendlichen,
und wir sind eher so ein bisschen da als Mentholen halt auf den auf den Rahmen zu achten. Also ich,
Behaupte auch, das ist mein mein Hauptskill ist, dass ich regelmäßig auf die Uhr schaue, weil wenn man einmal so im Coden drin ist und vielleicht so in einer dreier, vierer zehner Gruppe richtig, richtig schön am hacken grade ist, dann vergisst man total schnell die Zeit und da ist es manchmal hilfreich einfach,
zu grätschen, sagen, hey, mach doch mal Pause, redet mal miteinander und so weiter und ähm oft gar nicht so sehr das Technische, also das,
ist halt je nach Gruppe unterschiedlich. Manchmal gibt's auch Gruppen, die viel technischen Input brauchen, aber meistens ist es so, selbst wenn ihr am Anfang wirklich blutige Anfänger innen sind am Ende des Wochenendes haben die dich überholt, weil die wirklich so krass schnell lernen immer.
Ja, ich habe das ich glaube nur ein oder zwei Mal gemacht. Ich muss gerade versuchen, mich zu erinnern. Ähm als als Mentor bei bei Jugendhakt mitgearbeitet, es war,
sehr also auch sehr fordernd, weil die also alle so aufgedreht sind und so voller Tatendrang und ich stehe da, also damals war ich ja, da war ich ja zehn Jahre jünger,
und das die aber auch das äh hat äh das war also das ist eine sehr also ist anstrengend aber auch erfüllend äh und sehr,
sehr inspirieren. Da müssen sie am Ende äh alle ihre ihre Ergebnisse präsentieren oder dürfen,
Dann äh gibt's gab's da oder damals noch irgendwie so einen Preis, der dann da verliehen wurde Konkurrenzkampf das will man ja irgendwie nicht. Die sollen ja eigentlich zusammen.
Alle zusammen sich an an Dingen erfreuen. So, das hat hat für dich gewirkt. Dann ist ja schon mal super, weil,
Früchte von solchen Programmen erntet man ja dann eben erst 1 Jahre später, wenn die Leute nicht mehr jung sind und äh mal ähnlich was mit ihnen anfangen kann und da bist du jetzt,
Bist du jetzt äh ähm hast du diesen diesen äh Baudrang, lebst du jetzt äh in deinem in deinem Freizeitkollektiv Zerforschung aus?
Ich würde Bau sagen, Baudrang ist etwas weniger. Wir finden eigentlich mehr Sachen, die kaputt sind. Genau, zur Forschung ist ein Projekt, das ähm hat irgendwie so ein bisschen während dieser Pandemie angefangen, als wir alle zu Hause im,
im Homeoffice saßen oder was auch immer man dann zu Hause gemacht hat und uns allen langweilig war so außerhalb der üblichen Tätigkeit und da haben wir halt gesagt, okay wir.
Setzen uns einfach häufiger in Videokonferenzen zusammen mit so ein paar Freundinnen ähm am Anfang einfach zum Coworken und dann hat sich daraus halt Stück für Stück diese diese Zerforschung ähm,
wo wir uns einfach zusammen, wo wir verschiedene Projekte zusammen machen. Also wir haben ein paar konstruktive Projekte, ähm wir haben mal angefangen,
nach Corona in der U-Bahn zu suchen sozusagen. Also wir haben kleine Messgeräte gebaut, die die Signale der Corona-Warn-App aufzeichnen konnten und ähm die dann einfach mal in so ein paar U-Bahn hinterlassen und geschaut,
Wie viel positive Leute Treff trifft man eigentlich so im ÖPNV und,
Wahrscheinlich ist es eigentlich, ähm dass dass man dort halt auf eine positive Person trifft, weil's irgendwie immer hieß, ja wissen wir alles nicht und wegen Datenschutz kann man das auch alles gar nicht erfassen und da haben wir uns gedacht, na sollte doch eigentlich trotz Datenschutz ähm,
eigentlich ganz guten Corona-Warn-App gehen und haben uns da einfach mal rangesetzt und so ein bisschen.
Habt ihr kleine ESP 32 mit Batterien versorgt?
Genau, also so Mikrochip, drei Batterien dran, die haben dann so etwa zehn Tage gehalten und dann in den U-Bahnen verteilt und,
auch mit Absicht in Berlin die U-Bahn genommen, denn die haben WLAN und die konnten dann einfach regelmäßig nach Hause funken und da konnten wir die ganze Zeit schon live sehen.
Was die so beobachtet haben und ähm hatten vor allen Dingen großen Vorteil, dass falls die Geräte mal verloren gehen, weil irgendwann ist der Akku leer und dann findet man sie nicht mehr,
hatten wir die Daten schon. An der Stelle wär's vielleicht nochmal ganz wichtig, kurz zu erläutern, wie diese Corona-Warn-App denn eigentlich ja, funktioniert, damit es nicht äh verstört.
Ich versuch's ganz.
Na ja, also okay, mache es mal äh ganz kurz. Ich wollte nur sozusagen auf das Prinzip einer hergehen, weil damit klar wird, dass hier quasi etwas genutzt wird, ohne dass jetzt in irgendeiner Form einen Datenschutz ausgehebelt wird, weil das halt nicht geht.
Genau, die die Idee hinter der Corona-Warn-App ist, dass eure Handys einfach alle paar Sekunden ein Signal aussenden und da steht eine zufällige Zahl drin. Und die wechselt sich alle paar Minuten und man kann das halt alles nicht miteinander zusammen.
Und ähm wenn ich jetzt hier so mein Handy habe, dann zeichnet das auf, was ihr alle für Signale aussendet und ähm kann damit erstmal nichts machen, weil sie sind in irgendwelche zufälligen Zahlen. Was soll ich,
soll ich daraus lesen? Ähm solltet ihr jetzt aber positiv getestet werden, dann werden all diese Zahlen, die ihr ausgesendet habt, einmal veröffentlicht und dann kann ich plötzlich kann mein Handy sich die alle runterladen und schauen, welche davon habe ich auf meiner Liste von Nummern, die ich schon mal gesehen habe, stehen auch,
Corona-Warn-App aufm Server und sieht dann halt, okay, da war ich mit einer positiven Person in Kontakt.
14 Tagen.
Genau.
Und ähm genau das konnten wir dann eben auch machen. Wir hatten halt nicht Handys ausgelegt, weil Handys in der Berliner U-Bahn so sehr vertraut der Berlinerinnen nicht. Und selbst mit den großen Powerbanks ähm kriegen wir da keine zehn Tage hin,
und konnten dann halt im Nachhinein auswerten und haben.
Das ist jetzt etwas unspektakuläres Ende gesehen. Ja die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist halt ungefähr so hoch wie die Gesamtinzidenz, also im Rahmen der Messungenauigkeit, die halt super hoch war, weil wir 24 Geräte oder so in über zwei Wochen verteilt, ähm ausgebracht haben.
Ich fand das ein super äh Technikexperiment, weil ähm natürlich ist,
am Anfang noch so keiner gekommen, aber im Prinzip wäre das ja eine ein schöner Pandemie-Ometer äh auch gewesen. Ja, wenn man also wirklich mal in allen U-Bahnen generell diese äh ITs eingesammelt hätte, weil's ja eben kein Problem ist und dann,
quasi wirklich mal abbilden kann. So sieht's aus, so äh ist sozusagen die Infektionshäufigkeit äh.
Uhr acht Alter. Es ist die U acht.
Also wir konnten keine U-Bahn äh finden, wo es wo es wirklich mehr gab oder weniger. Also es war alles so im Rahmen der Messungenauigkeit war es überall gleich so ungefähr.
Und ich glaube wie viel wie viel corona unterwegs ist sieht man ja eigentlich vor allem auch schon einfach an den Tests. Also die sind ja immer Voraussetzung auch um mit der Corona-Warn etwas zu machen,
aber der Wehren voll spannende Use Cases möglich gewesen. Also,
Ähm zum Beispiel die können die können natürlich diese ISBs können natürlich die Signale der Krone Warn App aufzeichnen. Die können aber auch einfach schauen, wie viele Geräte sich um mich herum die Bluetooth anhaben oder die W-Lan anhaben,
ähm und so abschätzen, wie viele Menschen sind im Umkreis. Das gibt es gibt's auch fertige Projekte für und ähm,
wahrscheinlich aus Google Maps und so weiter, dass da dann steht, okay, der Zug ist eher voll, der nächste ist eher leer,
Das ganz das wird halt gemacht, weil viele Leute Google Maps nutzen und Google dann daraus die Daten ziehen kann. Das geht aber natürlich auch alles irgendwie datensparsam und dezentral,
könnten auch die Verkehrsbetriebe zum Beispiel selber machen, indem sie einfach sagen, okay, wir kleben ein paar von den Dingern da rein. Die kosten wirklich nicht viel,
Die Technik ist mehr oder weniger da und dann veröffentlichen wir das von uns aus, können's vielleicht in unseren eigenen Apps anzeigen.
Veröffentlicht sind als Open Data, damit Leute damit nochmal spannende Analysen fahren und haben auch selber mehr Daten, wo die Leute, wann fahren, wo viel los ist, wo wenig los ist, wo man Takt mal nachverdichten sollte oder.
Aber das wäre doch die Leute arbeitslos, die da mit Zetteln äh an den äh an der Tür sitzen und irgendwie das so abstreichen, wie viel Leute jetzt.
Die können ja dann ISBS zum Beispiel äh aufbringen, also.
Ja ja, also da da geht auf jeden Fall noch so einiges. Also das das ist so eine typische Zerforscherei, die ihr da äh gemacht habt und wo ihr im Prinzip dieser ganze Hacking,
Gedanke auch tief drin verwurzelt ist. Ah da funktioniert irgendwas, da kann man vielleicht was machen mit wenig Geld. Wie können wir das irgendwie hinbekommen?
Ihr versteht euch auch als als Hackerin und Hacker so aber dann war ja.
Destruktiv.
Pandemie und äh da gab's ja noch mehr anzuschauen und äh.
Ich muss ja sagen, ich habe einen Dienst von euch sehr intensiv genutzt und zwar habt ihr ja ähm so einen Dienst gemacht, wo man einfach schauen kann, äh ist
dieser Test, den ich jetzt kaufen kann im Supermarkt, ein guter Test oder ein schlechter Test, ne? Weil am Anfang war man ja
wenn man überhaupt irgendeinen Test kaufen konnte oder sich online über irgendwelche äh dubiosen Kanäle etwas sichern konnte, aber ähm dann irgendwann war ganz viel aufm Markt. Äh dann war aber schnell klar so
die sind nicht alle gut.
Genau ja, das war dann also die die.
Konstruktiv.
Anfang einundzwanzig, äh das war dann Anfang zweiundzwanzig, äh weil wir selber Schnelltests gekauft hatten und dann hatte das Paul-Ehrlich-Institut als eben Bundesbehörde sich verschiedene Tests mal angeschaut,
geschaut, wie gut sind die tatsächlich, weil die Hersteller äh müssen sich das nur selber äh attestieren und die sagen natürlich ja ja, neunundneunzig Prozent sechsundneunzig Prozent, hundert Prozent, erkennen wir alles. Selbst die kein Virus haben, haben wir alle erkannt in unseren Tests,
und dann hat das Paul Ehrlich Institut mal nachgemessen und teilweise gesehen, ja okay, die erkennen gar nichts oder so. Ähm und.
Die haben nicht wirklich nachgemessen, sondern die veröffentlichen nur in diesem zentralen Dokument, was die offiziellen Angaben der Hersteller.
Die messen tatsächlich nach. Die haben genau, die haben äh unabhängig evaluiert. Mhm. Und ähm selber nochmal eben mit verschiedenen Methoden, ist aber sehr ausführlich da beschrieben, äh tatsächlich echte Proben nochmal genommen,
mit dann etwas kleineren Personenanzahlen, aber eben unabhängiger und vielleicht meiner Meinung nach aussagekräftiger.
Als PDF hinten im Internet.
Es gibt diesen Spruch so äh alle Geheimnisse der Welt sind an einem nicht auffindbaren, nicht maschinenlesbaren PDF,
so ist es da auch als wir damit angefangen haben war es tatsächlich einfach ein nicht maschinenlesbares PDF wir haben da auch mal lieb nachgefragt, eine E-Mail geschrieben hey habt ihr vielleicht ein Excel Sheet für uns? Wäre ganz cool, könnte man Sachen einfacher machen hieß es nee, können wir euch leider nicht geben,
Ähm und dann haben wir uns hingesetzt und haben tatsächlich aus diesem PDF äh raus extrahiert, die ganzen Werte, die ganzen Testhersteller und so weiter,
und haben da eine kleine Website gebaut, Schnelltest Test Punkt DE ähm funktioniert auch jetzt noch wunderbar, wo man dann ähm wo man die Hersteller eingeben konnte, Testname eingeben und dann sah man das Ergebnis, dass halt auch Leute zum äh vor uns schon gemacht, Spektrum zum Beispiel ähm.
Nicht eingibt, sondern.
Genau dann der Unterschied. Wir haben uns gedacht A das ist halt supernervig so. Ich bin im Supermarkt, da sind 1 verschiedene Tests. Die haben Namen wie super schwer abzutippen sind, teilweise steht dann an, steht der richtige Name nur irgendwo klein auf der Rückseite,
was wir ja eigentlich wollen ist den Barcodes gehen und wenn wir die im Supermarkt kaufen ist eh ein Barcode drauf, damit's am Ende kassiert werden kann,
Also sind wir in alle Supermärkte bei uns in die Umgebung gegangen, haben einmal Fotos gemacht von allen Tests ähm von den von den Barcodes,
haben damit einfach eine kleine Daten angelegt. Gibt's auch nicht zentralisiert. Wusste ich auch vorher nicht. Ich dachte, da hätte schon mal jemand irgendwo zentral eine Liste. Gibt's alles nicht.
Und ähm das war eben dann das Killer-Feature sozusagen, dass man einfach mit dem Smartphone äh den Barcode scannen konnte und es einem direkt sagt, es ist ein guter Test, ist das ein schlechter Test und wie gut ist der jetzt wirklich,
und das haben wir dann irgendwie online gestellt und hatten gar nicht damit gerechnet, dass das wirklich der so richtig nutzt,
Wir heißen mal eine nette Spielerei. Haben wir irgendwie in zwei Nächten zusammen gecodet. Schickt uns eine Mail mit schickt uns. Das war ein Fehler. Wir haben das irgendwie sechs Uhr, sechs Uhr morgens ähm veröffentlicht,
die meisten von uns auch noch geschlafen ähm mit halt ja, schreibt uns einfach an die normale Halloween-Zerforschung, auch ein E-Mail.
Ähm ich war noch nicht ganz wach, dann so um acht oder so, da da war schon großer Alarm in unserer Chatgruppe, weil der Mädels aber sich beschwerte, dass er langsam voll ist. Das E-Mail-Passfach war voll.
Und da haben wir schnell noch andere Lösungen eingerichtet und so weiter, ordentliches Ticketing-System dahinter, äh Ticketsystem dahinter gestellt und haben dann bis heute, glaube ich, ungefähr 9000 E-Mails,
mit Leuten, die halt meinten, ja hier, da fehlt noch ein Barcode, ähm ich habe euch mal ein Foto damit geschickt, damit ihr das nachtragen könnt und haben dann,
teilweise wirklich so sechs E-Mails pro Sekunde ähm versucht so gut es ging abzuarbeiten, aber das wurde immer nur mehr und da haben wir auch ein paar Tage nicht viel anderes gemacht als E-Mails abarbeiten und Bugs fixe.
Also waren Bugs, Verbesserungsvorschläge und Unvollständigkeiten vor allem Unvollständigkeiten, also.
So ein bisschen geschaut, wirklich grobe Schnitzer waren nicht mehr drin. Wir haben noch ein paar kleinere Sachen äh eingebaut, aber vor allem war es wirklich die Tests nach tragen die Testnacht.
Das wurde auch gut gefeatured, also ich glaube bei Spiegel gab einen Spiegelartikel drüber oder so, ne und dann.
Auch so in diesen in diesen äh Werbetafeln, in den U-Bahnhöfen waren wir irgendwie mal einen halben Tag drinne.
Und ähm wir bekamen auch ähm wir bekamen nicht nur böse E-Mails von unserem ähm von unserem E-Mail-Server, dass er langsam voll ist, sondern auch eine sehr sehr nette Masolu-Nachricht von unserem Hoster, die großartigen Leute von, die meinen so, ey,
voll cooles Projekt, was ihr habt, aber ihr macht ganz schön viel Traffic. Lasst uns mal reden, sonst wird das teuer für uns.
Weil das auch nur so eine kleine Webseite, ne.
Ja ja, es war auch alles, also es war auch alles lokal, funktioniert alles offline, ähnlich wie hier die die Timetable App, so wir sehen nicht, welche Tests abgerufen werden, wir sehen einmal, okay, du lädst dir die App oder du lädst dir diese Website runter, danach ist alles lokal in deinem Browser und wir kriegen nichts mehr mit,
das hat halt schon gereicht, weil das halt irgendwie hunderttausende Leute aufgerufen haben.
Bestimmt alle Anbieter auch bedankt, ne?
Oh ja wir hatten auch äh ein paar Anbieter, die sich beschwerten, dass wir so schlechte Werte für sie veröffentlicht haben und sonst mit Abmahnungen gedroht haben und die Daten waren,
Genauso die meinten dann halt so, ja, es gibt halt schon eine neuere Version des Tests und die ist nicht in den Daten drinne, aber genau, wir haben dann bei manchen den Hinweis rangepackt, aber.
Eure eigentlichen ähm Objekte der Begierde bei eurer bei eurer Pandemie-Coping waren die Testzentren. Damit habt ihr ja richtig Welle äh gemacht,
Ähm weil ihr ja selber mal Tests gemacht habt, irgendwo hingelaufen seid und euch gedacht habt, wie werden die denn gespeichert?
Genau. Also am Anfang war's tatsächlich dieses wie, wie funktioniert das eigentlich? Es war äh Anfang März, es war alles neu. Ähm es war total spannend. Wir haben uns natürlich verantwortungsbewusst auch selber testen lassen einfach,
und haben uns danach mal dieses System angeschaut und man so oh krass 15 Minuten die müssen ja krasse Abläufe haben, dass das alles klappt und so viele Leute wie wie machen die das technisch, haben uns halt die,
die Website äh die Technik der Website so ein bisschen angeschaut und haben dann gesehen, ah da gibt's irgendwie so eine Stelle, da wird unser eigenes Testergebnis abgerufen und da steht hinten so eine Nummer dran,
und ähm dann haben wir so uns an unsere Kindheit erinnert, so Graf Zahl, ja, zählen wir mal eins runter,
dann hatten wir ein fremdes Testergebnis in der Hand. Und ähm haben wir noch ein bisschen runtergezogen. Da kamen immer weitere, haben wir mal geschaut, okay eins geht, so ein paar tausend geht und 140.tausend geht,
so richtig Muffensausen, weil wir so halbwegs sicher waren, das sind jetzt 140.000 Testergebnisse, dann haben wir Linus angerufen.
Der saß gerade in der Lokbuchnetzpolitik aufzeichnung ähm und hat danach mit uns eben mal ein bisschen besprochen, was wir da machen. Dann haben wir die äh Sicherheitslücke verantwortungsvoll an den Hersteller gemeldet und das wurde auch alles geschlossen, haben einen Blogpost drüber geschrieben und dachten erstmal.
Jetzt gehen wir woanders testen.
Ja und dann haben wir das gemacht,
Haben wir den gleichen das gleiche Spiel nochmal gespielt und ähm ich weiß nicht, wie viel wir veröffentlicht haben, aber ich glaube fünf, sechs, sieben Anbieter müssten's inzwischen sein, also es wäre wirklich so eine ganze Reihe. Es gab eine Zeit, wo in meinem direkten Umfeld kein Anbieter war, wo wir nicht schon mal,
Sicherheitslücke gefunden hatten.
Das ist ich äh es also es ist äh es passt natürlich auch wieder alles zusammen, ne. Da wird dann schnell was gebastelt.
Und es werden halt die simpelsten Fehler gemacht. Ich erinnere mich noch, dass du irgendwann mal sagtest ähm,
Linus, du musst wissen, wir sind ja jetzt nicht irgendwie wild dran gegangen. Wir sind eher so wie Leute, den Gebrauchtwagen kaufen und prüfend gegen den Reifen treten und manchmal der Motor. Und dann fällt halt das Auto auseinander.
Was eben auch was er zeigt dass das, finde ich, haben eure Blogposts auch immer so schön in ihrer Ausführlichkeit erklärt.
Das eben nicht irgendwie wilde Hacker machen irgendwas kaputt, sondern ganz katastrophale, lächerliche,
Qualitätsmängel die die niemand machen darf. Ja. Punkt.
Irgendwer schrieb neulich der Rolem was. Äh unser Lieblingstrick ist das IDs hoch und runterzählen und ist es halt in ich weiß nicht wie viel, wahrscheinlich in ungefähr der Hälfte der Fällen haben wir irgendwo mal eine Nummer hoch und runtergezählt und plötzlich,
fremde Daten in den Händen gehalten. Als hier bei der bei der Planet C äh die das Testkonzept äh gebaut wurde, das digitale,
ihr dann auch nochmal beraten. Ich weiß auch, dass der Nils im Ines können wir mal mit denen reden, es wäre cool, wenn die mal alle Tricks sagen, dass wir gucken können, dass wir diese Fehler nicht machen. Das war dann,
sehr schön Hirte auch gehalten, aber wir haben's sicherheitshalber eben nochmal alles anonymisiert, aber äh das war auf jeden Fall auch eine nette Hilfe, dass ihr da dieses Wissen so schön,
weitergegeben hat.
Gar nicht, ob die ob da so viel Wissen wirklich rübergeflossen ist, weil es wie gesagt das meiste, was wir machen, sind wirklich die absoluten Basics und ich.
Du hast dann, also wie viele Testzentren habt ihr aufgemacht? Also ihr habt, glaube ich, gar nicht alle mehr verblockt oder wir wollten immer nur so einen Sammelblockpost machen irgendwann haben wir das sein lassen, ne, weil.
Schauen wir mal, vielleicht irgendwann kommt der Rest noch, aber wir haben wir haben eine lange Liste mit Sachen, die wir uns mal genauer angeschaut haben, wo wir Sicherheitslücken gefunden haben und wir schaffen's einfach gar nicht, alles zu verbloggen, weil dann doch immer noch was dazwischen kommt.
Wie ist denn eure Erfahrung jetzt in dem in der Zusammenarbeit mit den Anbieterinnen oder in der Zusammenarbeit mit dem Z-Bund. Ihr habt ja immer direkt einen Datenschutzbeauftragte,
Bund und die ähm Herstellerin gemeldet. Wie ist da so eure Erfahrung mit.
Es schwankt total, also wir haben manche Anbieter, die,
Antworten gar nicht und dann kriegt man dann irgendwann, dann schaut man eine Woche später nochmal nach, weil man die gerade nerven will ähm und dann ist plötzlich behoben. Eigentlich sagen wir aber, wir wollen von den Anbietern innerhalb von so,
48 Stunden hätten wir gerne irgendeine Rückmeldung. Nur so einen, hey, wir haben's bekommen. Wir arbeiten dran. Morgen ist es geschlossen was Größeres und ähm manche sind da total proaktiv. Inzwischen haben wir auch einige, die sagen, hach.
Lesen eure Blogpost eigentlich. Wir finden voll cool, was ihr macht. Das ist äh wir haben euch den Lockbuch Netzpolitik gehört. Oh, das ist uns jetzt erwischt, das ärgert uns ja schon sehr. Ähm,
Kontakt mit euch. Wir haben eine sehr offinelle dann sollen die uns lieber mal eine E-Mail schreiben als als ähm da die personenbezogenen Daten.
Ist ja voll.
Inzwischen kommt alles an. Wir haben Schnelltest-Edge, das äh ist ein anderes Postfach als unser normales. Ähm genau mit dem mit dem Verbund ähm haben wir eigentlich eine sehr gute Zusammenarbeit immer, die versuchen wirklich ähm.
Da viel zu machen, den äh Sicherheitsforschenden zu helfen, ähm da gute Prozesse auch bei den Unternehmen zu etablieren und ähm.
Also der Security-Team.
Genau, das ist der bunteste Security-Team des Bundes. Die sind eigentlich dafür da, dass die Bundesinfrastruktur von irgendwelchen Bundesbehörden und so weiter sicher ist,
Aber ähm wenn Sie die Ressourcen haben, unterstützen Sie halt auch Leute, die Ihnen ähm sicher melden dabei, die eben an die Hersteller ranzutragen und die dort zu schließen. Da ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen, was man bedenken muss. Ähm,
dass der Bodenteil des äh Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik ist, das BSI und das BSI ist bei dem hier, so beim Innenministerium, wo eben auch die ganzen Geheimdienst angesiedelt sind. Das heißt.
Wir tun uns auch manchmal schwer, ob wir denen jetzt wirklich alles sagen und sagen, denen auch manche Geschichten nicht, wenn wir sagen, okay, da könnte man zum Beispiel einen Staatstrojaner draus bauen. Muss man halt vorsichtig sein. Die geben sich Mühe und ich glaube nicht, dass die Leute vom Verbund das wirklich gerne weitersagen, aber.
Irgendwie die die Weisungsbefugnisse sind, weiß ich jetzt auch.
Sie sind wahrscheinlich nicht Admin Ihres eigenen Mailservers. Reicht.
Hoch- und runterzähl. Der hat euch aber jetzt, äh wo das mit den Tests langsam zum Ende kommt.
Zu den Gesundheits genau, es gibt.
Gesundheitsapps geführt. Die Gesundheitsapp, äh das ist das ist so faszinierender Unsinn allein schon. Erklär mal.
Na ja, eigentlich ist das ja eine ganz gute Idee. Man sagt irgendwie, es gibt wir haben jetzt alle diese Smartphones, wir haben alle Rechner, es gibt diese ganze coole Digitalisierung ähm,
könnte doch eigentlich Leuten auch äh mit ihrer Gesundheit helfen, nicht nur indem sie sich eben schnell testen lassen können, keine Leute anstecken, sondern auch mit,
anderen Problemen, sei es ähm dass sie Rückenschmerzen haben zum Beispiel und dann eine App haben, die ihnen die ihnen Übungen zeigt und mit ihnen die Macht oder so. Ähm,
Das hilft den Leuten bei ihrer Gesundheit. Das sollte eigentlich irgendwie von der Krankenkasse bezahlt werden. Ist so ein bisschen die Gedanken, weil die Apps kosten oft gar nicht so wenig Geld und wenn dann der Probemonat mal alle ist, macht man's dann doch oft nicht weiter,
Also hat Jens Spahn sich irgendwann 2019 die digitalen Gesundheitsapps ausgedacht. Das war das Braindinger für die die das Braining war die App auf Rezept.
Da wurde dann super schnell 'n wirklich sehr schlechtes Verfahren zusammengeschustert,
was sich womit sich Anbieter darauf bewerben können, dann müssen sie irgendwie eine lange Checkliste ausfüllen und dann können sie von den Krankenkassen erstattet werden und ähm.
Uns das alles angeschaut. Wir haben irgendwie diesen Prozess gesehen oder davon gehört und haben uns das und waren so okay, das ist.
Alles basierend auf den Herstellerangaben, die dürfen quasi, die müssen wirklich nur sagen, ja zutreffen, zutreffen, zutreffen, wir sind toll, wir sind die Besten, wir sind sicher, dürfen sich aussuchen, welche Krankheiten ihre Apps beihilft ähm müssen und müssen zum Start nicht mal,
die Wirkung nachweisen können, sondern ähm sagen einfach, müssen nur vorweisen, wie sie das innerhalb eines Jahres prüfen, ob sie wirklich helfen.
Also so wie Homöopathie.
Homöopathie als App.
Genau, ja, nur, dass die Apps, also nur das Homöopathie halt wirklich nicht wirkt. Apps könnten es ja zumindest.
Auch welche, die wirken. Also ich hatte auch schon Erfolg äh mit solchen Apps tatsächlich.
Ja genau, also es gibt ja auch aber auch von ähm Leuten gehört, die halt irgendwie genau gerade so Rücken-Apps, so wir sitzen alle viel zu viel. Da mal eine App, die einen trägt.
So Diagnose-Apps, wo man so Frage antwortenmäßig sich kann so, ich habe hier das und das, was könnte das sein? Und damit habe ich schon mal so einen Blinddarmdurchbruch diagnostiziert. Also nicht bei mir, aber bei jemand anders.
Aber mal als Interesse, wenn man da wirklich als Hersteller einfach alles angeben kann, könnte auch eine Esoterikanbieter einfach sagen, so ja ich habe hier eine App, die sagt ihr halt irgendwie, mach die drei Zaubersteine hier so und das hilft gegen Rücken, könnte theoretisch, ne?
Ich weiß nicht, ob da noch also da schaut auf jeden Fall ein Mensch drauf, vielleicht wenn's zu krass ist, würden die's bemerken, aber also wirklich was nachweisen müssen sie halt nicht. Wahrscheinlich ginge das sogar. Gott. Ja.
Euer Zielpublikum des Podcasts safe, oder?
Und ähm,
Genau und die äh auch schön, die Anbieter dürfen sich selber ausdenken, wie viel es kostet. Das erste Jahr haben die quasi wirklich alle Freiheiten des Fast-Track-Verfahrenes wirklich für die Hersteller glaube ich großartig. Ähm.
Und also das sieht man, um kurz beim Preis noch zu bleiben. Das sieht man auch wirklich, die Anbieter kosten das kostet dann irgendwie ein paar hundert bis tausend Euro im Jahr,
ähm beim ähm es gab eine App, die war vorher eine Migräne-App, die war vorher schon als App einfach verfügbar, die konnte man sich selber kaufen. Das wenigsten sind neu entwickelte Apps ähm.
Und davor hatte ich glaube ich 65 Euro im Jahr gekostet und danach achthundert irgendwas. In dem Moment die Krankenkasse zahlt, dann ist ja auch egal und,
uns kam das alles irgendwie komisch vor, wir dachten okay, das sind irgendwie so alle Red Flags, die wir so gesehen haben, schnell zusammengebaut, wenig Kontrolle, ähm,
kleine Anbieter, die sich da zum ersten Mal probieren. Das kann vielleicht geht's gut, aber das sieht irgendwie erstmal komisch aus. Wir schauen da mal genauer hin und dann haben wir,
sind paar Apps angeschaut, bei weitem nicht alle und sind relativ schnell fündig geworden bei zwei Anbietern namens äh Cancado und Novego. Sehr nicht sagenden Namen,
Ähm Novigo ist eine App, die ist als zugelassen für Depression in allen Schweregraden.
Die soll einem dabei helfen, indem sie einem Videos anzeigt, wo man, ich glaube, Verhaltens äh Therapiemethoden lernt und eben ähm äh an sich selber dann anwenden soll und regelmäßig,
eingibt, äh wie's einem grad gibt. Also so eine Standardfragebogen einem dann irgendeinen Score ausrechnet und ähm Cancado ist zugelassen als Brustkrebsapp.
Und äh einerseits äh für die Kommunikation zwischen Ärztinnen und Patientinnen,
ähm wo man irgendwie einträgt, welche Medikamente verschrieben wurden, wie's einem grad geht, äh welche Nebenwirkungen festgestellt werden können und,
um äh Symptome einzutragen und das ist das, äh was es dann auch automatisch macht, weil so rein Kommunikation äh ist noch keine nach der Giga-Verordnung. Ähm dass man.
Sagt wie's einem gerade geht und die App sagt einem dann ah ja dann solltest du sofort mit dem Arzt drüber reden oder ja das hat noch ein bisschen Zeit bis deine Ärztin davon äh wissen muss,
Und äh wir haben uns dann eben wir das immer so machen, wir haben uns da mal angemeldet, einen Account angelegt, ein bisschen rumgeschaut und sind relativ schnell fündig geworden und haben äh viele Daten.
Habt ihr die gekauft oder euch verschreiben lassen oder wie seid ihr da überhaupt drangekommen?
Ähm bei äh jetzt muss ich schauen, in welcher Reihenfolge bei Novego war's so, da konnte man sich auch einfach registrieren, weil die's beides Sachen sind ja auch vorher schon verfügbar waren,
Man hätte sich das auch selber kaufen können und ähm wir haben uns einfach mal registriert. Wir haben noch nichts gekauft,
sondern ähm das hat schon ausgereicht, weil ähm dann gab's den schön, die Daten Selbstauskunft,
bei bei war's bei Novigo, da gab's äh halt so irgendwo tief in den Einstellungen konnte man sich alle Daten bei sich herunterladen und wir haben das einfach mal ausprobiert und dann stand wieder in der URL irgendwo eine Nummer drin und dann haben wir uns gedacht.
Einfach mal hochzählen. Ja.
Und ähm es hat funktioniert. Dann bekamen wir kurz darauf, wieder einen Zip zugeschickt,
ähm den ganzen Daten einer anderen Person und das waren bei äh bei Nowego glaube ich so um die zehn.000 Leute so in der Größenordnung.
Das mit den Depressionen.
Mit Depression halt, mit super privaten Daten, also ähm irgendwie, weshalb hat man sich angemeldet, ähm einem User nehmen, der total oft äh vor einem Nachname war, ähm E-Mail-Adressen und eben, wie geht's einem regelmäßig?
Was ja, was ja schon einfach krasse Daten sind und bei ähm,
Was etwas anders, da konnten wir uns als ähm konnte man sich einfach als Ärztin registrieren, was an sich ja nicht schlimm ist, weil ähm so eine Ärztin hat ja noch keine Patientinnen, die müssen einem ja zugeordnet werden.
Und ähm eine Ärztin kann aber alles runterladen.
Nee, tatsächlich nicht. Die äh wir haben erst mal geschaut, die Endpunkte wirken alle halbwegs sicher. Ähm da konnte man nicht einfach so Sachen runterladen. Aber wir sagen so, okay, es gibt für alles so eine eigene Schnittstelle, so äh für die Patientinnen und so weiter und,
Es gab aber irgendwie nichts für die Krankenhausabteilungen. Da haben wir einfach mal geraten Slash Departments für die Abteilungen und dann hatten wir eben nicht nur die Daten, wie sonst überall die Daten, auf die wir zugreifen sollten, sondern,
alle Abteilungen, eine Liste aller Abteilungen noch an sich noch nicht schlimm, weil wir äh,
Krankenhaus A hat, Neunkologie und eine was auch immer, ist irgendwie ja sind öffentliche Informationen mehr oder weniger. Vielleicht noch welche Ärztinnen da sind, sind schon etwas privater, aber dann konnten wir's auch bearbeiten. Und dann konnten wir halt einfach sagen, äh ja, wir arbeiten übrigens in dieser Abteilung,
Und damit hatten wir dann eben, damit waren wir Ärztinnen in der Abteilung und konnten alle Sachen abrufen, die in dieser Abteilung.
Ging mit allen Abteilungen. Das ging.
Allen Abteilungen und dann hatten wir alle Daten, auch da also 300 Leute haben das als Giga verschrieben bekommen, ähm aber die App hatte auch noch anderen Anwendungen, das ging's glaube ich vor allem um Medizinprodukte, Studien war eins der größeren,
die der Hersteller gemacht hat und da konnten wir auch eben von ich glaube so zehn, 12tausend Leuten.
Muss man ja meistens auch Vorerkrankungen und alles Mögliche angeben, ne.
Das war also das äh das war richtig krass, was wir da alles sagen. Halt wirklich mit 8 Uhr zwei Tablette genommen, acht Uhr fünf Tablette genommen, keine Nebenwirkungen, Blutdruckwerte, wie geht's einem? Ähm was hat man für Symptome, voll stillstehender Name, Adresse, E-Mail-Adresse, Telefonnummer.
Alles.
Also dieser Fehler mit den Departments, ja also blöd ähm immerhin nicht ganz so einfach zu finden.
Wenn wir's erraten konnten in relativ kurzer Zeit sie haben's halt einfach vergessen. Sie hatten das mal eingebaut, dann brauchten sie's nicht mehr und dann haben sie vergessen das abzuschalten.
Also den den Endpunkt ähm.
Wenigstens etwas, wo man ein bisschen suchen muss, dass bei dem Export hoch und runter zu zählen. Ich glaube, dass wir das äh wahrscheinlich sogar automatisch in Burbsuit, wenn du dich einfach wahrscheinlich dadurch klickst.
Was glaubst du? Super schöne letzte Frage. Wie kann man dieses Problem lösen? Also ich meine.
Gut, ich ich arbeite in dem Bereich. Mein Lösungsvorschlag ist, äh lasst Leute draufschauen, bevor ihr so einen Mist veröffentlicht. Aber das ist ja immer nur ein freiwilliges Angebot, was wie kann jetzt.
Und hilft auch nicht immer. Also ein Endpunkt, der abgeschaltet ist, den man errät, findet im Zweifelsfall die.
Das meinte ich nämlich grade, dass kann man auch mal den kann auch mal jemand übersehen haben, könnte sogar sein, dass die einen Pantest hatten.
Wie kriegt man das jetzt für diese DiGars gelöst? Weil also als ihr anrieft und sagtet, ja Linus Digas, wo ich schon so oh nein. Oh nein! Die Idee, die klingt halt völlig bescheuert, wenn man euch kennt.
Ähm was was was würdet ihr daraus folgern? Also was was was können wir da jetzt machen?
Na ich glaube, es gibt halt irgendwie so zwei Sachen. Das eine ist halt irgendwie ähm,
die Regulierung schauen und eben auf das also ich glaube wir haben ganz gut Regulierung mit der Datenschutzgrundverordnung, die eben viel vorschreibt, aber die Sachen, die dort drinnen stehen, müssen auch irgendwie umgesetzt werden. Und wir,
Datenschutzbehörden, die teilweise eben nicht ausreichend viel machen, weil sie nicht genug Ressourcen haben oder weil sie ähm die Felder manchmal auch nicht ganz so sehen, ähm die dann zwar schnell aktiv werden, wenn man ihnen Bescheid sagt, aber ähm vorher auch nicht,
die müssten eben einerseits proaktiv dahinter sein und zum anderen auch mal Strafen wagen, wenn so ein Kram schiefgeht. Andererseits braucht es einfach auf der Herstellerinnenseite,
braucht es einfach diese Priorisierung. Also es kann nicht sein, dass IT Security immer so ein Ding ist, dass dann halt mal hinten runterfällt, was man dann mal, wenn man schnell das neue Feature launcht, dann macht man's erstmal und dann schaut man, dass man's noch sicher bekommt, weil wenn's einmal draußen ist, dann,
die Priorität schnell woanders und gerade bei diesen digitalen Gesundheitsapps muss man sich wirklich fragen, ob's diese Daten so überhaupt.
Das sind Corona-Testzentrum, die eine E-Mail schreiben muss,
ist irgendwie klar, aber dass deine Depressionsapp, die ähm dir Videos anzeigt und einen Score berechnet, dass nicht einfach alles lokal macht auf deinem Rechner oder dass die App, wo du mit deiner Ärztin redest, dass nicht alles nur auf deinem Gerät macht und in dem Moment, wo du's deiner Ärztin schicken willst,
geht's erst raus und dann Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt bis zu Ärzten, sodass Leute, die eben mal ähm in dieses System reinschauen, gar keine nutzbaren Daten vorfinden,
Das müsste eigentlich einfach so sein. Das müsste eigentlich Voraussetzung sein. Das müsste vielleicht auch einfach bei diesen Dias nochmal explizit abgefragt werden, aber,
Das müsste einfach so die Grundlage sein, weil natürlich braucht es diese IT-Sicherheit oben drüber, aber wenn mal was schiefgeht, braucht es halt irgendwie noch so eine zweite Sicherheitsebene und das könnten halt Datenminimierungen, Verschlüsselung und solche Verfahren sein.
Datensparsamkeit. Okay, ich glaube Tim, wir müssen jetzt auf die Uhr schauen, ne.
Jetzt sagen wir erstmal danke, Karl für deine äh möchtest du die anderen noch erwähnen?
Dir fällt dein Einnahme nicht ein äh nicht alle äh mit Namen äh auftauchen.
Könnt ihr also noch mal unter Forschung Don Ork sehen, einen Blog, das zu lesen, sich lohnt.
Ja, kommen wir langsam zum Ende. Ähm wir sind ja hier auf der Fusion und die Fusion ist ja auch so ein Ort, wo's um ja Freiheit geht, so und äh.
Freiräume auch geht. Du warst äh glaube ich auf dem Chaos Communication Camp, dem letzten, was ja so ein bisschen das das HK-Equivalent äh zu Fusion ist, wenn man das so sagen darf.
Das war deine das war deine erste dein erstes Camp. Wie.
Bei dem anderen Camp war ja noch viel zu jung.
Ja, macht ja nichts. Ich.
Aber es hat nicht geklappt.
Aber ich würde äh von euch beiden ähm weißt du wann warst du das erste Mal so Camp Open Air.
Feiern. Also worauf ich ein bisschen hinaus will, ist, es hat sich ja parallel zu dieser ähm,
Technoparty Kultur, die hier schon, weiß nicht, Fusion gibt's jetzt auch schon seit äh siebenundneunzig, ne, irgendwie achtundneunzig.
Also schon so ein so ein Vierteljahrhundert im Prinzip, das ist ja schon einiges. Ähm,
hat sich ja auch einiges entwickelt, so das gab's so in der Form vorher nicht und es ist ja auch äh wie man hier sieht auch durch das Content, wo wir jetzt hier gerade sind, wo ja quasi,
die Partykultur auf einmal in die Inhalte reingrätscht so war's ja dann äh beim Camp eher anders herum,
Also wie hast du das wahrgenommen, wie äh wie wie wie was was denkst du bewirkt das und wie passt das auch zu dem, was du hier siehst.
Einfache Frage.
Ja zum Ende ganz mit Bitte um kurze Antwort, nochmal so eine gigantische Frage.
Wir brauchen nur von dir und dann schalten wir direkt das Spiel zurück. Na was fällt dir dazu ein? Wie war das für dich.
Also ich meine, dass das Camp und auch so eine Fusion ist halt immer großartig, weil man halt super viele Leute trifft, super viel ähm auch nochmal andere Erfahrungen macht, mit Leuten nochmal anders reden kann,
Ich glaube, das braucht das einfach so, solche Open-Air-Räume, solche freien Räume allgemein, braucht es halt viel mehr, wie's auch,
sind, wo es dann besonders weh tut, wenn äh wie in Ulm hattet ihr auch letztes Mal in der Sendung solche Spaces dann plötzlich von,
ähm Gruppen, die das nicht ganz so verstehen, wie dann eben einer Stadtverwaltung zerstört werden.
Trotzdem ist ja jetzt die Zerforschung äh in Corona in einem in einem entstanden.
Inem, das vom Verschwörerhaus. Es war der dicke Button vom Verschwörhaus, weil viele von uns in diesen Räumen aktiv sind.
Also du sagst, es ist wichtig, aber für dich persönlich keinen keinen wichtigen Teil in der Prägung zu zu dem, was du jetzt machst.
Äh doch, auf jeden Fall, also weniger dieser Open Air Events, aber halt so freie Räume, wie es eben auch Jugendhakt sind, wie es auch äh jugendhakt versucht, eben aus einem,
mal die die teilnehmenden aus diesem schulischen Kontext, wo alles so sehr strikt ist rauszunehmen und halt ein Wochenende einfach mal laufen zu lassen und die krasse Projekte zu machen,
braucht es einfach und so was ähm diese Entfaltung braucht es einfach, diese Möglichkeit.
Du begleitest es ja schon länger ähm das Camp. Wie wie siehst du das? Wie sich das auch entwickelt hat. Also es äh also vor allem so als Parallele Veranstaltungen, zu dem, was wir hier sehen.
Also für mich geht's da vor allem also bei ja so dieser,
Festivalkultur auch aus der Hackerszene, vielleicht auch um Kreativität, ja also es ist nicht nur ähm schaue, wie kann ich mit kreativ mit Technik umgehen, sondern vor allem wie kann ich mit kreativ mit Gesellschaft umgehen. Und ich meine, bei ja, so Festivalveranstaltungen, das ist punktuell. Man,
bildet dann natürlich Netzwerke. Man lernt sich anders kennen. Man kommt vielleicht auch mit anderen Impulsen in Kontakt,
für mich tatsächlich aber super wichtig war auf meinem Weg, so gerade als äh sehr junger Mensch.
Offene Räume, die permanent da sind, die nicht kommerziell sind, die ich nutzen kann. Also es fängt ja ganz einfach an. Ich habe eine Gruppe von Gleichgesinnten. Wir haben Bock, was zu machen,
treffen wir uns? Haben wir ähm die Kohle uns die ganze Zeit in der Kneipe zu treffen und gibt es halt vielleicht eine politische Kneipe auch, die sagt so, ey ihr könnt umsonst um unseren Hinterraum nutzen,
eine Ausstellung machen und dann gibt's halt irgendwie den Club der sagt so ach weißt du was, äh Geld ist mir egal, macht euer politisches Ding und,
dass so etwas zufällig immer da war, ne, wo man halt aktiv war oder dass man jemanden kannte, der da vernetzt ist,
unglaublich wichtig und ich find's ähm schrecklich zu sehen, dass teilweise Räume, ähm in denen ich früher zu Studienzeiten, Schulzeiten sehr aktiv war,
immer mal wieder gefährdet war, nur teilweise sich auch vollkommen verändert haben oder verschwunden sind.
Also werden wir dafür weiter kämpfen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Genau. Chem gibt's vielleicht bald wieder. Kongress auch und äh das äh ist auch bitter nötig.
Nochmal vielen Dank Karl und wir sagen vielen Dank fürs Dabeisein, fürs Zuhören hier bei Lockbrot Netzpolitik. Das war's. Unsere 434. Ausgabe, pünktlich angefangen und fast pünktlich beendet.
Vielen Dank.
Vielen, vielen Dank, dass ihr gekommen seid. Es gab ja wenig Alternativen hier. Danke für die Einladung.